[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yo brown what is going on fine
sunday
morning
how's my levels what's going on
talk to me christopher i see you project
x talk is supposed to get you in here
soon
hustler motivate what's up brother let
me know i'm sounding smitty smith the
legendary death mobile kevin list you
already know ranger fan i like that
armando sanchez what's going on talk to
me no doubt akw no doubt thank you
hustle thank you akw
sick
and and and triple n sharp in the chair
let's go big bad mo let's go dj orals
what's going on get out of butler ranger
fan
what's good uh attic talk to the people
[Music]
mucho chucho i like that
okay
because yeah see mucho chucho said attic
is a little low commander ottoman akw
attic a bit of all the levels just a
little bit a little bit i think cause he
he real quiet and tired what about now
a little bit better
a little bit louder yeah i think the
music we got a lot of that's cool thomas
what's going on so yeah we're gonna get
the x talk the muffin mine up in there
you know what i'm saying and then i was
a little king of the deals coming
through
corey mosley what up you know what i'm
saying so uh look we're getting popping
good show
and uh get ready y'all
so
[Music]
[Music]
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they're
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on the song with me that's
understandable i kill a beat and they
want to compare me to freddie and jason
i'd rather be hannibal they'd be like
why use a video game just be original
y'all so dramatical i know it's random
but i'm addicted to flipping the sample
and making it flammable this is that
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but coming to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beating they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
but they'd be like why use a video game
just be original y'all so dramatical i
know it's random but i'm addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal i got it
don't stop
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i always
been a nerd never been a loser making
voltron with a gang of cougars and i'm
going places better tell her uber cause
it's pretty hard to sleep on freddy
krueger that's who
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beating they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that
they call the department and i get the
blame still i'll be running collecting
them rings you just a target when i'm in
the range i was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
[Music]
ain't gonna hold you i ain't here to boy
you you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you i always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is that yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
i'm embarrassed for you always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal i got it
[Music]
um i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boil you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i've
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger that's
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
[Music]
be swearing they real but come to find
out that they really mechanical and yeah
i be eating these rappers but that's all
a part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i am
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable this is that
fire this is
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people on
aim
check my vocals on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
um
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boil you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i've
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people on
aim
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social lower my city but i'm still
by coastal i got this switch
what did you do
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with
the gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until the time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but coming to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was
[Music]
look i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you ain't gotta say it
i'm embarrassed for you i've always been
a nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
that's
who let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
[Music]
turn me to an animal and haters be
swearing they real but come to find out
that they really mechanical and yeah i
be eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on the song with me that's
understandable i kill a beat and they
want to compare me to freddie and jason
i'd rather be hannibal they'd be like
why use a video game just be original
y'all so dramatical i know it's random
but i'm addicted to flipping the sample
and making it flammable this is that
this is the yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
check my vocals follow on twitter but
i'm anti-social love my city
[Music]
you ain't gotta say it i'm embarrassed
for you i've always been a nerd never
been a loser making voltron with a gang
of cougars and i'm going places better
tell her uber cause it's pretty hard to
sleep on freddy krueger
[Music]
is
[Music]
and watch so many snacks in the attic i
wanted to chill with the pack and be
like a young wolf but then they would
mistake me for addict if i can imagine
it's cool to give you some advice and
invite your girl to your squadron cause
if you don't give her that option you're
gonna be single player like siren you're
gonna get tossed in the bushes by king
david royalty ain't not a pretender
detrimental to an elemental what's an
avatar to a knee bender i gotta be me
though i know it's my destiny word to
cognito who cares if you fly if you
steal a mosquito you swear you ain't
something but really
you like to collect stuff and that's
cool but i got bad news even if you
really was that you can't never still be
the king of the statues since the
juvenile i've been cursed with a curse
to be musical and if you hate it we'll
meet in the crucible wasn't it nothing
it's cool and it's beautiful we let you
know that your dreams are pursuable
whatever you want to do then is doable
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on a lord's day
[Music]
mike let me just fix this we are
ridiculously funny right now they just
fixed this right here cause they could
play card it's always cut off when you
start in this live now it's not cut off
for this live and
we are live
welcome to the iron lords podcast llc
and also live on lords of gaming.net
episode number 233 it is another
glorious sunday we're back in front of
the round table on the lord's day i'm
extremely excited about our special
guest and we've got halo infinite
campaign and multi-player rumors
new xbox exclusive leaks and a global
chip shortage to discuss so we're going
to get right into it
i want to introduce the lord who is not
only up and coming within the realm of
podcasting and content creation but is
slowly making his ascension within the
xbox and multi-platform gaming
communities
introducing
the co-founder and host of the project x
talk podcast and youtube channel
the lord of turn-based strategy
who sometimes clowns the dedication of
his panel
yet our every bit the journalists they
pretend to be
live from upstate new york and making
his debut into the realm of the lord
my man lord kevin aka the muffin man how
we doing sir i am great i always
wondered i was like what's my intro
going to be because i listen to your i
listen to your awesome intros every week
and i'm like what what could that mind
be and that was like way above anything
i could have expected so i'm i'm amazed
you a lot of what you do it's long
overdue we talking for a little bit you
know what i'm saying good to have you to
realm new voices in the community man so
first of all how are you and what you've
been playing man
i'm great um and
right now i'm playing a few things so i
am playing on my playstation 5 um
sly cooper collection through ks now
because
i you know around september after i beat
cana i was like
there's nothing for me to play on this
console so i'm gonna defeat and then
okay yeah
i can't feel your pain yo
i just posted that yesterday i said it's
gonna be a dry season for you guys here
we go a little bit i'm like when's the
next playstation game i want to play i
don't really know it's like starting off
crazy
i i got that ps now and i was like i'm
gonna play sly cooper because ps5 is my
ps5 is my first playstation ever so i've
never yeah
um okay so did you um
[Music]
go crazy left no no no no did you get
online did you do the traditional stand
online get your console stuff like that
uh how did you get yours i bought mine
through someone in the community for
uh 550. so it was like just above retail
price
okay yeah that's a friend that's a
friend got you get it got you for this
oh yeah don't even know
because a lot of people have like
stories or whatever how they got this
like oh i got mine through stockx or
something like that and it finally went
through in the in the box
[Music]
king wanted like an adventure story i
traveled the deserts
no no no some people was out there
fighting for this like it's really crazy
no i mean no i just i hit up facebook
marketplace some dude was like yeah i
give it to you for like 50 bucks more
and i'm like wow and then oh you got
lucky
like an
i had four of them kept one i sold three
for three thousand each
with a game and a controller so yeah
lucky you didn't run into me
it's like the the guy i bought mine from
i saw later on he was selling more but
he learned he's like i gotta mark these
up and they started going for 1200 i was
like wow i really got in there so you
got it on the ground floor okay
got him before he knew what's up you got
him when he had a good heart
[Laughter]
see my heart was black from the
beginning oh my gosh
anyway
we're gonna get into it more to discuss
but uh you know we got those four
horsemen of gaming those original lords
of the realm here at the round table my
codes with the colboast my brother from
another mother the difficult game
conqueror lord of his own world and the
how of the young wolf my man lord addict
how we doing sir
doing pretty good so i guess uh i gotta
do do the report on a ninja gaiden yeah
so yeah people people
hold on
but also i bend the knee to my man with
the knife that was stabbing you
shout out to the dogs that kept running
into him and making him bouncing off the
football dude
shout out to the dudes with the ninjas
quarterback sister
yeah i've never laughed so hard man
man i
that game is a lot of like members a
cause they all move it i like identical
like what's funny is like like they'll
pop up those those football plays out of
nowhere like you'll just be walking and
and
then like there's a mish i think it's
like like stage three where literally
the entire stage there's no no no
cheetahs no whatsoever and then at the
very end
a chia comes out of nowhere just to hit
you off the map
shout out to the invisible like the game
dev was just so punishingly bad where
they just kept respawning and coming at
you with the same energy you know you
know what it is right because those
games those early nes games were still
built with like arcade you know thinking
in mind right so they weren't thinking
like let's make it easier for the guys
at home they paid 60 dollars whatever 80
whatever it is nah y'all gonna suffer
the same way you do as if we're trying
to get quarters out of you
you know it's so funny because when you
see at you know when addicts mad when he
starts when he starts doing that that
belittling lisp voice
this sucks and i'm like oh my god it's
bad
he's bad
i like when he was going after the the
the viewers
he was like why do you keep talking
about magic why would he have magic why
would he have madness he's a ninja
right now
that's like cheating what the hell is
going on here and i'm like
you was annoying me at first but then i
found out that you just had to crouch
and they were really easy to kill yeah
just a little just a little end zone
just turn that look
i'm just i'm booming still it was just
slightly it's just slightly um yeah just
turn yourself actually turn yourself
slightly down you'll just move it a
little bit but what about now yeah
yeah so it was a fun experience like i
can't say i hated it but
like the
the
the people with the guns was crazy like
it's funny it's like they'll put a
person with a gun and then like three
karate dudes acting like they from from
from the karate kid like right after
that then you think you good and you
walk it it like and then bam two
football players and i'm just like like
i guess like that
they the inconsistency didn't make sense
to me but like it was still a fun game
but and i didn't feel like it was a
little bit sometimes like unresponsive
yeah yeah because sometimes i feel like
i i know i clicked that button
you're you're going down no
when you don't have a bubble face tv
you're gonna get a little bit in for
that yeah
and i like how he was doing the climbing
mechanic and doing the hop hop back and
forth
why does he automatically stop why did
he stick
why is he sticking to the wall
yeah it was a little ridiculous man it
was funny is i fought a boss
that
like if i had to jump around them they
would hit me
and then it would throw me into the wall
and he wouldn't get off the wall
and then and then there's some kind of
glitch that happens because sometimes
like most of the time it would be fine
but there'd be times where like i'd be
on the wall
and i would be stuck on the wall and i
was showing them the screen i'm like i'm
pressing the button it's like nothing
happening but then when i press start
and i unpause it then it would let me
jump off the wall yeah like which is
sometimes very high
i'm sitting there showing
proof that this glitch exists
and the chat is claiming it doesn't
like
they're just trolling you this is just
you but i like difficult gay cockroach
playing these old-school games the
stream was fire yo check that out it's
up right now at the time the title was
fine what you got millennial plays
millenniums play ninja gaiden first time
well what you should have named it was
a young man old versus old games
i was going more for like an algorithm
thing like yeah people people
they'll put in
you know the people love throwing out
millenniums gen z and stuff they're
going to be typing that into the chat
more than anything else i was like well
you know what let me let me name it
millennials
yeah
this week is shinobi
i'm shotgun on the side play haters
where you at with that one where is it
it's it's it's friday friday at 5 00 p.m
so i got to play that i think that's on
the xbox yeah that's what xbox 36 let's
go i i i'ma play that this friday
it was it was it was a fun experience
like i i really had no issue with it
uh but
i doubt i'll jump back on to uh to ninja
gaiden
i don't think i'm uh
i'm about that too much like but i do
like the boss fights in that game i
really enjoyed those balls that one boy
she thought was gonna take a long time
he's like um but probably gonna die you
beat him i was like oh man
oh you talking about the one that jumped
left to right yeah you did that that was
the only one that was the only boss i
didn't like is because it was just like
there was nothing oh jump left jump
right jump left jump right jump left
like like and then it's like every other
one you shoot bullets at me and then it
took me a minute to find out you can
actually use you can actually hit the
bullets well i guess you know oh yeah
yeah that was a big goal
here man but it was but one thing i will
give that game
is that music's on point yo music i was
listening i was like
he turned into oprah
and he was like you'll get a shuriken
you'll get a [ __ ]
that's because i was so i didn't know
like i found out later because people
was like you don't have enough ninjutsu
and i'm like what do you mean ninjutsu
like
but they were talking about like that
number because you have to use like five
for the share kid and like eight or ten
for the fight to use the ability yeah
first off whoever put that fire
ability in that game was trolling
because that thing is utterly useless
every time i would use that it wouldn't
like i it's mainly i know what it is
it's been for ad control but it's just
like
towards like the the the plat the the
platforming stuff i learned it was just
easier just to avoid them entirely
entirely than it was killing them
some are clearly better than others but
no doubt we got to move on i know you
got uh a little elder ring real quick i
know real quick oh yeah yeah um okay so
i'm not gonna go too much in the elder
rings because i am going to i am going
to have a video out for eldon wearing so
definitely look out for that it probably
be i'll probably do it today and i'll
schedule it for tomorrow but okay i
played about 10 hours of that game and
uh i'll give you guys my it'll be on the
iop channel this channel you're watching
on it probably tomorrow about 10 a.m no
doubt shout out to ksi they said lord
young blood out here owning these
classics salute to you lord actually
absolutely i got to chapter five
he's almost done he's no doubt and of
course we have almost technical gaming
lord the solo gamer who lives for the
single player selfish experience and
also the sastradamus the lord of clarity
and lord patron of the iron bank my man
lord sovereign how are we doing sir
i'm doing good i've been doing very very
well good until i i threw on the the gta
trilogy
my heart sank a little bit
about that
but then i went back before the horizon
as well you know everything
everything everything um
just
the fact one little thing that they did
from four to five that makes all the
difference is
that pretty much everything is
destructible in five whereas there were
more walls and there were more things
that you ran into
in four like
foliage stuff like that now pretty much
everything only like if you see like a
humongous tree stump probably yeah that
would stop you yeah but apart from that
you can break everything so now that
that freedom you get like i'm not gonna
take the road i'm gonna take this field
and run over all these all these flowers
or whatever
the freedom is that much greater than in
four and it's for whatever reason it
makes all the difference because
honestly the racing is great the racing
is fantastic but it's probably
the least fun part about that game
because the most fun is just going
around the world
jumps and whatever stuff yeah yeah but
yo that game and then gta man like gta
what's going on i heard the streets
it's not lit is that lit the character
models are gonna get over right i can
get over there
yeah now now this is we talk about gta 3
gta vice city and san andreas
why do these games first of all why do
they have a fidelity or a performance
mode why why is it a 30 fps option in
these games at all
you know what the high quality i am
disgusted that there's even the option
to do this in these games
off the rip it should automatically
happen
what is going on here all right so so
then that right
there are some guys that like that 30
frames yeah yeah you know very filming
you know it's very interesting
i wouldn't call it gta 3 filmic
you know what's funny speaking speaking
of that like mentality of that like
default settings i remember when i was
playing death loop they put the the
default setting to have uh the the chick
talk through the controller right so i'm
sitting there missed like multiple of
the dialogue because i didn't realize i
had a headset on i didn't realize i
didn't realize it was talking out of the
controller and then i'm sitting there
and i'm hearing her talk like really
faintly and then i was like why do you
make that the default setting like yes
that's weird continue so they didn't
want to use that controller yeah
i've only played gta 3 and some of my
city i haven't even thrown on san
andreas yet
um but another thing that's an issue is
just the lighting and
the the color setup like the colors are
washed out the black the blacks are
crushed off the rip so it's almost like
i i actually didn't check if it actually
applies hdr if it does apply hdr if if
there's any way to turn it off just turn
it off and use sdr you know when you
when you load into a game right and the
initial screen is very bright and
popping and then it gets dim when they
apply the hdr yeah it's because the hdr
is kind of messed up so if you could go
back to just just just regular sort of
color and forget about hdr it'll
probably possibly yeah hdr battery
yeah it seems like that's what it is
because i have uh shout out to kybotsu
because i had to really drop contrast
all the way yeah and then bring up
brightness to even get it close to
looking decent throughout the game
anonymous he said turn off bloom it sort
of solved his problem yeah and then
bloom i wanted to leave it in there but
that was another thing i had to turn off
i was like i just gotta go
so we we're talking about the gta stuff
right yeah
yeah that that that that is one of the
biggest i want your monies i'm going to
do the least amount of possible i've
seen in a while that's the thing they
didn't do it right so that there you go
right there what was the name of the
team that did it because i almost grew
up the grove street something like that
road street edition
that's not like a gang in the warriors
we got the the westchester razorstrike
[Music]
so they took that name right but it's
the team that did the the mobile ports
and the mobile ports there was a lot of
it looked great on your phone right
probably fantastic but that's about it
um
yeah so so this this in my the contents
there it's still fun obviously this
stuff hasn't super aged it aged super
well it's there it's still fun but it's
not what it could be and it's certainly
not a definitive edition
so before we get over to
let's get these super checks they flying
in i don't want to give that to you go
on real quick let's just do king real
quick and they'll do it before yeah
let's go okay
yeah let's do it because there's a bunch
coming in
so real quick uh big shout out to mr
real nonstop talent shout out my man we
are king
check out mr real nonstop talent on
youtube i had an interview with him
last week king also probably two weeks
prior to that i had an interview with
him it's all on his channel check it out
um really cool dude from caguas puerto
rico
fantastic so it was a good conversation
funny stuff
no doubt oh real quick girl shout out to
one away dragon tv he said you never
adjusted your tv to the game the hdr is
messed up if you slide the game into the
game all the way down it will fix it
till they patch it he dropping the video
on the ball one eight dragon go hit that
no no for sure don't don't touch your tv
settings no your tv is fine yeah don't
just mess with the game stuff just to
get it playable oh yeah another thing
it drops frames in performance mode
which is crazy
all right that's it i'm done
anyway it is what it is what it is
and of course we have the incredible
hulk of this aka the access gamer
the prophet of xbox swami king of the
statues who demands nothing less than
that premium experience it is the leader
of the fraud alert movement
be love it lord king how we doing sir
oh i'm doing fantastic after watching an
incredible probably fight of the year
yesterday with gabe uh rosado versus uh
javi maguire
um
the young boy got baptized last night oh
my man from queens
new york came through
please get the buddy with the bad yo
gabe
shout out to get gay face held up for
the fight you know
listen gabe gabe's own
one true claim to flame is his face
gives out right and um don't let that 13
losses see because you get all gassed up
right you did they were like gay rosado
21 with 13 losses
with 15 knockouts
right
you're not looking at the 15 knockouts
you're not looking at 21 those wins and
those knockout ratios kind of crazy and
you just looking at those 13 losses like
oh man this dude
yeah
gabe is about that whole life his face
is not about the life though but his
face stood up the whole 12 rounds he
baptized harvey
so bad in this fight harvey figured it
out like oh he's not a joke everybody
got to be taken serious young boy earned
his stripes last night and it was such a
great fight and you know i tweeted it
out because you know me and wifey and it
turning up yo i have other videos that i
couldn't put because i'm cursing
absolutely ridiculous
i found the only video that i could post
there was no curses
respecting them oh of course i'm not i'm
not about that you know you know oh
willy-nilly kirsten for no reason
all right so
granted grab that photo san andreas oh
you did it okay and my boy came in the
game passed
i don't appreciate that please pass me
more caviar
unfortunately was not caviar all right
so this this was more like this
this was more like tuna in the can oh no
not even albacore
it was it was
[Laughter]
on and i'm like yo cj coming back your
mom's gonna find out who killed your mom
the bad acting is there it is so fast at
me riding the bike
and i was like it took me back to those
first moments when san andreas
and i was like this is what put it over
the top for me it's audrey this is what
put
grand theft
in a different league for me let's go i
know we had the joints with the good
music and stuff like this but
this just felt i guess because it was
like uh the black representation of a
main character type of thing but it
wasn't
it wasn't just that it was just the the
feel of la if you've ever been to la it
had such a grounded feel of la the
character could have been any color but
the grounded feel of they they captured
the absolute city it was so good the
corrupt police i was just like i love
this game so much so i all overlooked a
lot of the issues like you said i went
in like performance mode like why would
this game like that
it's so old you should just be doing
this off the rip yeah but no sadly it
did not and bloom was in effect his bald
head off for the police officers i saw
the rain looking like like wow you're
like wow
i went back to that forza okay
nice and saw that i haven't been a forza
horizon dude all right
i i like i'll download them uh play them
and i'm just like
yeah whatever
this one has a little general sequoia to
it
a little something there something there
so i'm trying to figure out what it is
that it has right
and
it's the way they set up everything
the they learn like i'm pretty sure that
they learn from game to game
when a dude rides past you really
quickly you can press that x button and
it's like an action action pop up and
you can challenge him off the rift yeah
challenge him head head dude challenge
me here i'm like what's
i'm thinking we up run down the street
we're gonna go down the street right and
he was like
and broke off into into the
into the bushes
did this dude just run into the bushes
and he he beat me because i'm thinking
we racing traditional
this is all out get it while it's hot i
i love the fact that you buy houses
so i get what hdg and you guys are
talking about with the generic clothing
and why do you got joy and stuff you're
mad george
y'all all right that the character
himself is seen a lot so they would have
loved a little bit more diversity with
that character i don't like the fact
that i got to run with the skinny knee
dude yeah like
everybody eating you know just regular
tacos getting three tacos when i'm out
of here
it's it's it was really good um playing
uh destiny went right back to uh back
for blood no doubt
every time i go back to that game
it's like i'm i'm learning a little bit
more of of a fine meal it's like you're
getting different tastes uh oh they use
this and they use that that game is so
fantastic i can't say um more about it
but right now i'm i'm completely
satiated with what uh microsoft has
delivered for our holiday season i feel
sorry for my playstation dudes i know
it's going to be a little dry
until uh what is it y'all february mark
here we go
hopefully nothing slips but um
i don't understand i understand hey
y'all got ps now
yo
yo
that was messy anyway so i've got me to
go and dance with you guys okay go ahead
go ahead and then we'll do this with you
no doubt he messy and of course we have
the gaming the gym self the shinobi lord
cognito spread that rhythm to the realm
of the iop not telling what you want to
hear but what you need to hear shout out
to my boy maddie plays to finally do we
got two episodes up there right now free
99 to be up regular talk about that god
howard discussion and all that and then
um we had uh ultimate up for talking
just giving kind of forza it's roses so
check that if you want to be part of the
patreon
question cog yes sir did you get that um
that crunchyroll
is it part of um ultimate i believe is
it there yeah okay wait you just
straight up get it with ultimate you
have to pay additionally for no no you
have a free trial okay a crunchyroll
who owns crunchyroll games
yo
i never knew i needed something for 75
days more than i got this this trout
i'm going to rock my crunchy roll out
pause
i'm sorry i just wanted to know if you i
mean listen guys if you have game pass
i'm sorry that a hijack cog joint but
crunchyroll is available for you so if
you want to know what's all the hoopla
over there on the playstation oh this is
what you do you got it for free oh okay
okay thank you thank you for informing
me of what my subscription entails no i
didn't yeah this is really informative
of you oh yeah after that um shout out
to all the last word b e travis came
down um oh man we had my boy swifty tto
really cool one of the uh og content
creators what a sherpas grab master
specialist so he came through and also
gave his flowers as he moves on into
looks like the potentially game dev so
um it was really cool check that out if
you want and then king will be proud man
it's been a strong game past week for
[ __ ] strong game past week i got some
games beat i'm very proud of myself
put your hands together one more time
wait wait what are you drinking out of
sir oh this is the uh the latest at the
uh 10k uh team shop right now y'all go
get y'all oh
what did you say it's a new merch
big shout out to lord snowdo lord pete
the band hammer himself uh he will be
promoting our newest merch up very soon
so we have uh just to let you guys know
all natty just to clarify real quick
none of this says
this doesn't make addict
why did you just you planted the seed
right now
[Laughter]
i know he's hilarious so yeah we got a
lot of that new merch right now you know
what i'm saying we got all natty in that
building and we gotta fill dominus
maximus aurelius spencer in the building
the new philadelphia like yeah the new
jersey but we got donald's back this is
exactly thomas
you got to go to the store right now
check that out then we have little man
in the building rocking out doing his
thing showing his bra
and on top of that we have a very
special limited edition 10k line 10k
shirts 10 000 subscribers that is you
guys you guys made all you guys so that
is the newest stuff
petey's going to be promoting that soon
in case
up in front of everybody um yeah so just
you can go get it now though yeah let me
put the link in there and pin that so
the realm could get all that right now
hold on yep it's up there go check that
out links up there i'm gonna pin it it's
pinned go check that out new merch up in
the building yeah that all not on that
is like i've never seen a better
likeness of kids yeah
daddy is ridiculously king like it is so
good
he really did that you know what i'm
saying like
i love graphic design yeah so go check
that out go support go support yeah for
me like i said king would be very proud
like i said it's been game past week
finnish disco elysium absolutely amazing
amazing game you know we're going to
talk more about drop that in game pass
um no that is not a game pass but that's
why i didn't play it yeah that's fine
hopefully it'll come to you soon but um
what i did play game pass and beat was
forgotten city
that is an underrated gem that i didn't
i didn't see that one coming it was one
of those all right let me let me check
it out we had i think we had grub on
duke and he talked about it and maddie
was telling me about it and i'm like i
and i heard it was made like off a
skyrim mod or something someone told me
and yo let me tell you right now all
this talk about time paradox and do it
ain't nobody rock mess with no more how
to do a proper time paradox then the
whole like king you're gonna love it
because not to spoil there's a lot of um
historical references and civilizations
prior
and who stole from who all right so
you're talking about that gold joint
with the golden gun and the people was
dying the people turning the gold
and if you were about that greek
mythology you were about mythology and
the gods and bro you king
you need to play this game because i
know you need to play backbone okay so
what's up tell me about that but what's
bad boy all right so it's it's uh it's a
world where animals
are are
like they're they take the the
humans like our place right so
this guy's a detective but he's really
not a real good detective so since she
was playing uh disco leaders this was
kind of like bad detective too yeah
we'll go through this but um there's a
lot of text it's not um okay audio yeah
the disco the thing i like about disco
is a lot of audio but well just yeah
just to fit it like forgotten city
the best use of of of of the time power
like remember what 12 minutes and all
i'm trying to do because one thing i
hate about those games is once you start
figuring out and getting deeper i hate
when the loops start and then it's like
you got to do every single menial task
ever yeah no no no once you get to a
certain level of understanding there's
things in the game that you could be
like yo no no dude it's gonna
automatically do all that busy work that
you figured out on your own so you gotta
keep focusing on it and the narrative is
so well like i'm telling you right now
they really did that
yeah i feel
like it's like four different endings
i beat it i got like the second ending
which was okay
it was so good and i never do i was like
nah i gotta get the best and i got to
see what i got to go back because
they're like yo it's for you yeah it's
crazy so salute to that that's all i got
let's get these super chats cause we
definitely will
all right i'll be that give me one seven
minutes
while you do it while you're doing that
i'm ready to go oh you're ready
let's see let me run back we got the
dutch runner with the five dollar super
chat
cox said that he's got a little man in
the bedroom and he loves how
that was fine that that was a great
setup i got front
caught out there friend that was crazy
what you just did i was crazy boss it's
all when i see you though continue
[Laughter]
that was fine once again with the sequel
five dollars of attack that series f
little ma may not be able to touch the
bottom of a tuna can but can tear the
sides wow
who is dutch runner is he a bad boy
yeah
i forgot
he got in control
then we got tony right once again
remember for 16 months thank you so much
sir we got salute lords i hate missing
the show live gonna watch later we'll
join you guys tomorrow morning for the
anniversary show no doubt yeah funnel
slope
then we got lord metroid two dollar
super chat attic hold up and attack man
ninja gaiden
[Laughter]
i guess that was for him to use the his
powers
yeah he got he got the hoodie on salute
then we got [ __ ] jay
remember for four months shout out sir
good morning my neighbors no doubt my
brother good morning to you
then we got broken control with the five
dollar super chat we need a new ninja
gaiden amen to that yes yes yes we do we
do for sure
then we have either iron bear or ear
bear 32 uh new member let's put the
crest in the chat for the ear bear dirty
beer salute ear beer
the ear bear stare there we have it
[Music]
we have splendiferous remember for two
months
attic act like he was trolling him the
whole time he was giving him help wins
till he starts telling us how old we are
so we so beat the game
you know what's funny someone was
like spamming like cap like capital um
sentences whatever they're doing
everything was capitalized
and i thought he was trolling and i told
him to get him up out of there
and then and then and then i read it i
was like oh because they write him like
no he's just helping so i read what he
said i'm like oh i was like because you
know how you guys like you see people
yeah you like yo yeah you think you try
to be disrespectful
i'm not even reading it because i'm i i
remember the folks can we apologize to
the brother
well i apologize on the stream oh
google but uh yeah i i told the chat to
get him up out of there
wow
after you got him about the building
salute to you
you can show that situation get him out
of here
you know what's funny um
that the the mods wouldn't do it i just
noticed he was still there so
like they were like no it was wrong yeah
so yeah so uh
that's all right no doubt
that's that's funny
then we have
uh we have el nini five dollar super
chat is it me or have the playstation
fanboys been quiet lately i i
haven't noticed i haven't been checking
playstation fanboy twitter
[Music]
salute to the lords on another fine
sunday waiting for king to bring it
today with the xbox topics will we see
worldwide jim ryan today
next question alex
we have alex kilgore five dollar super
chat love your content guys wanted to
attend my first love show and give some
love live show thank you bro
it says love okay
gamonomics remember for one month shout
out the vote let's put the crest in the
chat for game and nominations
lessons the rope with the rupees up
salute bg what's up bro see you
then we got black in the building five
dollar super chat salute lord that 65
inch oled c1 is doing its thing gen x
problems yes brap just got his new c1
yeah that boy lessons man
i mean even though your playstation can
be played on your bubble face but that
xbox though
looks inside the brat man we just talked
here here he got he he's feeling real
good about his atmos that hdr that one
sweaty that he's feeling good right now
that c1 is a beautiful thing it really
is hdr
um what was all that crazy oh
you're ridiculous you're ridiculous you
know i gotta i gotta be messy with him
yeah i know you're being better he has
all the consoles eddie's do it use a pc
that's right there we have tyson lewis
uh two swiss francs
clarifying that thanks for making
sunday's dope love
frank oh they're sending franks that's
what's inside that frank's frank's
[Laughter]
there we are gerald mack five dollar
super chat oh hell the iop salute shout
out to the lords and the esteemed panel
thank you guys good dudes always repping
yeah yes sir
cedric h five dollar super chat more
like a can of sardines
in reference to the the gta trilogy yes
yes
it was loose
then let's put the crest in the chat for
matthew ritter oh thank you sir new
member in the round members put the
press up for the new member let's go and
we got black conflict x
that voice for the struggle put your
fist up he's [ __ ] struggle son i like
him you know what i'm saying
good morning lord good morning to you
sir thanks for watching
let me run back a little bit wow we got
a couple here
run them up bloody straight we got
spartan ghosts we got we got spartan
ghost
uh 17 two pound super chat backbone is
amazing get on it pause yeah okay
get on that backbone pause yeah get on
you do that
[Laughter]
now i'm obama remember
hit the like button and share yes yes we
have 5 41 in the chat right now let's
look like
i'm a dirty trigger lover
wow
if halo infinite multiplayer drops on
monday my little man will be on crystal
d
yo come on
come on hey you got that name the dirty
trick come on now
time for him
that being too much they've been really
too much continue yeah we got brian lane
two dollars super chat elden ring going
to be game of the year 2022 calling it
now
[Laughter]
no doubt that's me with that
there we got captain chats five pounds
super chat hoping to be playing some
halo on monday on my new halo infinite
console oh you got yours oh that's
fantastic
wait wait you said captain chaps
chats
it's already left
it's already left hey man take it any
further than it needs to be
continue
then we got black road in three five
seven five dollars per jack what up iop
realm i got vex smith last night
all right nerf for next month though
rock out as best you can you're about to
get nerfed then we got our five dollars
a chat from nathan langston thank you
sir appreciate it say something brother
say something say something say
something
everything is right
[Laughter]
then we got stitch two dollars of attack
cog i had to do it hashtag little man
hashtag crystal d
been listening to the lords for months
now rda crew talks highly of the lords i
had to check the lord it's one of the
best decisions i've ever made thank you
salute man much love thank you
yes sir and we
all right let me just get the merch and
then we did what we got to do all right
so this was from a couple from last week
it's phoenix down he got the classic
pullover hoodie he said oh love the pod
always look forward to spending
something with the lords then david hot
right bought a pint gas happy lord's day
let's get solved this manscaped
horse okay
somebody hit us in this yeah they saw i
go for assault like reading that an ad
for us or that would be kind of late i
go oh i already already man i'm ready
you know what i want to do i'm going to
do that squash soap because i'm in love
with that yeah
being that i'm a big dude not being in
the shower
and then david rodriguez he said hello
from australia best gaming podcast hands
down keep doing what you're doing guys
he got the traditional iop crest in
black salute this is my boy anonymous
with the tribal and t he got the knights
of the realm all four of us saluting
black then we got oh i feel dominance
put your name brother now you got the
phil dominance hoodie put your name up
you know what i'm saying
on twitter we got smitty smith with the
first all daddy t shout out to all the
playstation fanboys they are mad about
forza horizon 5 the book of acts okay
eight million smitty eight million we
got the book
so that was the last one shout out to
smitty but look we got to get into
the show everybody's [ __ ] out in the
chat but uh we we got a special guest
who's been very very patient so now we
got into what the laws were playing all
the super chats all that good stuff we
have to focus on lord muffinbond his
video games history his journey into
content creation and of course what led
him to creating the amazing project x
talk youtube channel so like kevin let's
start from the very beginning what were
some of the first video games you had
and what got you into gaming
so
if i have to go all the way back i think
that and it's something like i wouldn't
know right off the top my head about
thinking it's like my my grandma is
probably the main driver that got me and
my brother into games and it's not that
she played games herself
it's that she was really supportive of
us playing games
so like we didn't grow up in a very
wealthy household um but i had one
grandma who i would go visit very often
and i'm a millennial i'm 28. i'm talking
yeah so
i was born 93 obviously the nesr i come
out
snes but those were my first gaming
consoles she had them in the house for
whatever reason wow before grandma was a
down little gamer
grandma had these at the apparently okay
i don't she had them for some reason
but me and my brother
we would play
super mario brothers and that was really
like the only game we would play on
those because one could be luigi and one
could be mario and we're twins so we're
like they're brothers we're brothers
we're gonna we're gonna play some super
mario brothers and have a good time
there
um and i think you wasn't and that's the
question
okay so
when i'm when my daughters were younger
they're not twins i would dress them the
same all the time right
did you guys get to dress the same stuff
all the time yes
when did you rebel because my kids
rebelled about that dress
so i know it was a point where y'all was
just like it's over i got i don't want
to look like this dude
well what are you talking about he's
still dressing up like your mother
yeah
like that do you know so as as kids i
would probably say like
six or seven
probably yeah so it wasn't we would be
like all right we want to wear like
different clothes and then my grandma
would be like all right we get different
color of the same shirt that's that's
what you get because i'm buying the
clothes we we did that uh and then you
know throughout high school and
everything we uh we wore like black
t-shirts because we were very like much
into rock bands and whatever
yeah so we kind of looked the same long
hair we were very similar in high school
rocky back in the day oh it was really
rock us down okay oh yeah yeah but if
we're going back to
to gaming um i would say that i played
the nes the snes obviously but then it
was like the game boy and the n64 i
think were really like what i spent the
majority of time playing in like my
youth and what got me into like games as
i being hardcore into games let's get
some give me some games from both
platforms and attic this should be this
is you just your jack right here hi oh
you improving to this addict
yeah obviously
you know we're not talking we're not
talking about you know the ngts
we ain't talking about 18 versions of
tetris
you know
whatever that
yeah we good keep going man
give me some two standout games for
those two platforms
uh well stand up for n64 is uh smash
brothers obviously for me because
me and my brother would constantly we we
mainly looked for two player games
something you could play together
because we were we were playing together
no matter what we weren't doing single
player games so smash brothers was
something that we found were like these
are our favorite characters we're going
to put hours into this game
and then for game boy it was probably
pokemon just because you could
develop your team and then battle each
other with that
cable bringing it to school getting your
neighborhood friends together you know
you got pokemon what pokemon you got
let's trade pokemon
um see my my cousins would try to steal
my pokemon they wouldn't try to ask for
them they would try to steal them
i didn't know how to save my pokemon
when i first got it for like the first
week i would just keep i'm like this
game sucks i gotta keep starting getting
on the pokemon
i got kicked out of them
[Music]
that's what's up man so you got into the
the the nes whole ecosystem with that
point you got 64 rockets smell like a
real nintendo kid yeah i was about to
say like this is very nintendo
okay so you the nintendo kid was your
brother the nintendo kid or did he look
for other pastors no we were we were
both nintendo kids we did we did have a
sega genesis uh uh at home uh so when we
weren't our grandma's playing the
nintendo's that she got us uh we had a
psychogenesis at home so i was playing
things like golden axe i think was
probably my favorite over
now you better be playing that with your
brother with the co-op oh yeah
absolutely all right my man my man and
getting my little sister in over there
kicking the dwarfs and making the
bottles come out and get the potions
[Laughter]
childhood was very nintendo focus uh
even after like the n64 we went to the
the gamecube uh which
no like
anyone i know had a gay people give me a
gamecube level melee tales of simphonia
uh custom robo those are games that i
always like go back to as three of my
like big loves on that console they had
pokemon rpgs like
it's not just like normal pokemon games
they had actual pokemon games with
storylines and uh was it
um some kind of darkness the the pokemon
yeah yeah there's there's just so many
actual like games that they were like
you know it's we're not paying these you
know what's funny and pokemon coliseum
was literally
about you stealing other people's
pokemon like
like it's just crazy nintendo let that
game come out well you still in other
people's pokemon
that was the premise of it
yeah well then he had uh he had a
something attached to his arm where it
would pretty much turn the pokeball to
be able to steal other people's pokemon
so
like it was it was an interesting
concept there was two of them and then
they never done it ever again like
about the chat coming for you they said
no metroid prime i
so i'm not a metroid guy my brother
played metroid prime i'm not the i'm not
the metroid guy my brother is in the
chat
no because you know what i'm glad you
said that muffin man because
i respect you sir because he listening
y'all are not hearing he's nintendo to
the core
right he's been there from the beginning
the genesis if you will that was at his
house but he was there from the
beginning
and he said he not a metroid dude
there's a lot of metroid slamming sir oh
no no no because these dudes out here be
capping so why they can't wait
listen no no no we're not gonna do this
because i'm talking to an aficionado
here of nintendo all right he had it all
and he's chosen not to mess with metroid
because
that's why metroid is the least favorite
uh of a game or character from nintendo
go on sir you are really lighting it
oh you lighting it up for that nice real
quick
to roll it back to n64 for a second no
no no wrestling games
oh no yeah wrestling i was huge
wrestling growing up yeah yeah i
absolutely loved watching wwe even
throughout my teenage years i would
watch wwe play like raw versus smackdown
but
n64 had some classic wrestling games
okay okay well certified now he was
worried so i was worried about you oh
yeah he thought she was fraudulent you
didn't mention no wrestling game from
ncd4 we don't choose fraud but now you
go what about zelda games
uh i i like ocarina of time
is he certified addict he left it right
there he's like i like i can really tell
you right now
zelda gays yeah ocarina of time and then
age of seasons and uh major seasons yeah
the game boy you didn't play like my
girl's mask or anything on the n64 i
didn't say that i played it i don't know
oh i like it random challenges
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that's the favorite
my brother is in the chat actually shout
out and he reminded me of probably the
the game we sunk the most time into on
the gamecube fantasy star episode one
and two online online where the
yeah we probably played that game a
thousand two thousand plus hours like
grinding trying to get those drops that
it's like okay you got a point zero zero
zero one percent chance from this rappy
yeah so let's go for it let's find that
pink raffy that game
i love fantasy star oh he's so excited
when xbox brought it back oh yeah yeah
absolutely
it has it it had a a place you know like
because the online play and stuff like
that and you get a chance to see new
different people every time you was
getting on or your friends was playing
with you that
i really liked how they did their game i
can't get into it now because remember
it's like chambers you went inside one
chamber and then you had to clear out
the chamber then you can come back out
and then go back in and grind but yeah
i'm with you guys all the way out yeah a
little salute so yes you got like i said
got all this tremendous history nintendo
stuff like that then you go in the
gamecube then i love his brothers in the
chat yeah i like that shout out to the
bro with support i like that yeah i like
it i love that yeah um because i always
wanted to twin yeah
if we confirmed that he's a twitter
listen the havoc that i would have
caused wait rough about have we
confirmed this
yeah yeah i missed that
that's why i asked if they dressed them
the same got it completely missed that
my bad bad
going into study halls for each other
this is huge thank you
did you did you do the classic swapping
out dates thing
no no no no no
thank you
thank you
[Laughter]
in the chat
absolutely
what about with this i mean the parents
know like
would you be able to play gaming
tricks on the parents at eddie would you
twin them um
no i mean
so my grandma raised me okay um my my my
parents weren't my dad was around a
little bit but my parents weren't really
in the picture so it was kind of you
know we don't ride a bully old grandma
over there she's got enough taking care
of three kids
we were we're pretty good kids to be
honest though
i love the two i'm sure that's your
story
go after my grandmother
we'll get the uncut version of it
he said is this the real muffin man yeah
yo these addicts are full salute man so
you got that you got gabe cube you know
what i'm saying so then what was the
next transition
uh next transition would be to the xbox
the og xbox um didn't get it at launch
it wasn't until my neighbor came over
and he was like guys you gotta check
this console out he got it was he
actually halo 2 had already come out at
that point okay so he was like we're all
going to play this game and we fell in
love with halo 2. like just the
multi-player maps the crazy playground
yeah the dual wielding kneelers was my
jam
absolutely loved halo 2. so then we were
like chris was coming up grandma you
know
you've been hooking us up can we get can
we get one of these xboxes you know
they're not new and she did it she got
us so she got us an xbox yeah i'm loving
grandma come on yeah
this story goes on i'm loving grandpa
mom
yo mike i remember my grandparents knew
nothing about gaming or anything like
toy related they had no idea what the
kids were into
but they were always the one to the ones
to get me exactly what i wanted same now
my parents like my parents like oh this
is a reasonable facsimile no the
grandparents were the ones that got me
all the time like i was like you don't
know anything about it you know why
because they only had you for a brief
period of time there you go when you
came over they was like you know what
i'm gonna be the shining knight yeah
yeah
exactly what he wants my grandma's was
great both of my grandpops was dead
before i got there but
the grandmas though my grandma's is lit
so his grandma is like like champion
grandma right now and i'm loving this
right now
she got you that xbox let's go yeah i
like how astute she is with what they
interested in and i'm getting exactly
what was actually continued
oh yeah and she and she absolutely
worked her ass off sorry worked her off
uh to get us this to this stuff because
she she was the person collecting
bottles returning them at walmart
getting the 50 bucks like oh this is
this is going for my grandkids so she
really yeah yeah she really worked her
butt off to get us this stuff that we
cared about it's a little brother
tremendous story continue with the xbox
one my grandmother got me man was
grounded so
yo
yo you're ridiculous
okay i could have went left with that
yeah yeah i got to win i have went to a
game too but i was like yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's what i was going to leave it
alone
so we we got we got the xbox and from
there it was like okay we got we me we
missed a few years let's let's catch up
and um we got we went back to halo
combat evolved played the original one
we were like we got to catch up on the
story
uh fable i think is probably my favorite
uh what am i uh
maybe my favorite permanent fighter
you're gonna be on the attic show this
week
we've been looking for a fifth lord
talk about this fable let's go let's get
to i
i sunk so many hours and multiple
playthroughs into the original fable um
i would always i always do a good run
first like i'm like i'm going to be the
shiny beacon in this world i'm going to
do everything good but then like once
you do everything you're like all right
now i'm going to slaughter every
villager in this world i literally
cleared out the entire map one time
nobody
[Applause]
there's literally a temple in that game
yeah that you you sacrifice people too
yeah yeah you you get people you're like
oh you follow me man i need help and you
take him to this temple and then they
put him in a contraption and sacrifice
him yeah yeah
yes yes
is it wasn't that which one in the
beginning would eight like was it little
kids like taboo in that game you could
do yeah
you could kill little kids and yeah
somebody
yeah you could like you could murder
them and stack them in piles
someone was stacking them in piles when
they were doing
some promotion for fable and they and
they didn't notice what they were doing
was on the screen they they had to take
that out of the game who was it that
said that that peter molina was like oh
no
danny the one that brought that up i
think maybe it was
i forgot i did hear this story because
i'm trying to remember who i heard it
was an acg i believe it was like
a story yeah yeah yeah that's that
definitely sounds like it's not very
acg-ish
[Laughter]
oh yeah yeah
which is
what's your favorite fable
one
okay we're
we're in an agreement
i feel like i feel like the fable
franchise declined like for some reason
people think fable two was the best
i just i just think they're on crack or
something like i don't understand that
so edu educate me real quick though why
do the fable
lords feel that two is a regression so
to speak i'm just kidding so you mean
why are they wrong and we're right yes
it's just like i always felt like
fable one had such a great story
and such a great you know
atmosphere
you know they they connected a lot of
the uh you know side mission stuff like
there was an excalibur in fable
the one that you had to max all your
physical attributes have to even pull it
out of the sword
yeah they they there was a you know i
said there it was called the temple of
storms is where you sacrifice people but
there was another temple where you
donated money to the church
and if you had to sacrifice a certain
amount of people to get the dark sword
and you had to donate a certain amount
of money and you had can you keep in
mind you had to either be completely
good or completely bad to get these
weapons
and you would get the good sword from
them and
i gotta be real
probably the biggest reason fable one
was the goat over fable two is jack of
blades
so you know fable two didn't have a an
antagonist like that i don't i've never
seen
an antagonist like jack of blades ever
in gaming like he's literally like
you so like spoiler alert but this
game's like 25 years old
it's like there's a time where you're in
the call you you're you're raised with a
with like uh kind of like a
someone that you see is a rival you're
raised with a rival his name's whisper
her name's whispered so you you raised
your entire childhood with her you're
the ones that you always spar with to
learn new magic moves but then you get
to this coliseum
and you uh
you guys are both participating in the
coliseum so then you get to the final
like five rounds and then they make you
guys team up you and and whisper then
you get to the final round
where you think it's over jack of blades
gets up he's like
y'all give the uh both of you what do
you kill each other
it's
keep in mind they they were geniuses
when they made this because the amount
of money they were giving you was absurd
where you would like you could get it
just kill her kill whisper if you're
just sitting there like i've never been
like i'm looking at this and and jack
ablaze is like i'm giving you 20
thousand dollars and that's a lot of
money and i'm like do i really need this
chick around yo
yeah i killed her i killed her but
what's funny is like if you see it had
like if you killed her
her brother would be like a hidden boss
at the end of the game his name's
thunder
and you would have to fight him if you
killed whisper crazy crazy you know so
buffalo you agree fable one
yeah fable one definitely i feel like
there's more
more morality choices that like actually
have consequence like like addicts
saying over there i didn't really feel
like conflicted at any point in fable
two and i like fable three better than
fable two that might be controversial
but like even in fable three it's more
like do you wanna end the hunger of the
kingdom or do you wanna
yeah i didn't real like it wasn't i
didn't like how they did that like
i like fable two more than both of the
ones that y'all talking about
because one because i got it but second
one because it would be king
the level of families and stuff that you
can just be going out and making
information oh yeah
so this is the part that they're not
telling you this is why they joint was
whacked all right because you couldn't
go out and and spread your royal feed
about the crease
uh you could not do that and
and go have a wife here go have one [ __ ]
okay so me
that's why i still have part two that's
why i put up part two the other day
because i was out there i was the ladies
man inside fable too so
too that's all i just chose to do so i
didn't care about excalibur
i cared about owning houses it had
multiple wives all over the place
[Laughter]
legal procreation simulator my king
i want i prefer to have the next fable
be a sequel but i don't think that's
going to happen
but if it is a re if it is a recreation
of the original one
i would like i don't even care if they
reuse jack ablaze like that's how good
this individual because all he really is
is like he's a demon that the mask of
jack of blades
is is who he is he
the jesus
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
they can find out about each other like
they did and one got pissed off and left
me it took the kid
oh no you kill her take the kids
yes i said this is this is what i'm
talking about like you see it's the
other one's doing wait wait you can kill
her and take the kids if she tries to
leave my god
you know it's crazy there was a there
was a glitch in fa uh well it wasn't
really a glitch like they did uh a kind
of a system like because there's a rent
system in fable too they brought it over
from fable one but they did it by time
based on the console right so literally
in fable two if long you're not
connected to the internet you could buy
the very first place in fable one two
which is like not that expensive at all
then you can jump up the time on the the
system itself by like 99 years and come
back to like 20 billion dollars
wow wow
i'm sorry about that we diverted history
delayed because they can't fit in all
kings offspring
[Laughter]
shout out to king's offspring algorithm
oh good [ __ ] you're going back
into crates you say look we got xbox but
we um we missed out on all these games
faber was one of them and then you could
continue circuit yeah yeah uh kingdom
under fire another series that like
doesn't get enough love and i really
wish that there was like a revival of
that series because it combined like
hack and slash and real-time strategy
games with rpgs
yeah fantastic game but from the from
the xbox that was kind of like where we
started to start balancing like okay we
need the new nintendo console and we
need the new xbox console so we got we
got a 360 on launch for christmas
you know christmas but our grandma
hooked us up again she got us out hello
grandma
with the hard drive yeah not the one
with that she she knew not the arcade
one
yes
this is what i'm talking about let's go
yeah we got the hard drive we got gears
of war with it oh we
spent
teenage me and my brother probably not
old enough to buy this game by ourselves
but we spent all christmas chainsawing
through people and like this game is
amazing this is the greatest game we
ever played um
but our birthday was coming up and
nintendo had just released the wii um so
we're like grandma we need we need the
wii you know i'm pushing it
y'all pushing it yeah i just got that
360 come on now she she could not find
she waited in line or like hit someone
oh my god
she she i i this was like the original
scalpers
you know nugent she got us a wii like we
did not expect it for our birthday we
showed up i was like oh my god we're
getting the wii now playing wii sports
uh
super smash brothers brawl was like the
main main reason that we wanted that
console
unfortunately it turned out to be trash
but
uh yeah people people like melee more
than all that's that's everyone's
favorite yeah yeah well funny story
about the the we like we played a few
wii games which none are really
memorable in my mind uh and the wii was
actually like i don't like this
direction nintendo's going in and we
sold the we sold the wii pretty pretty
like a year afterwards or something like
we wow we sold it for money
you know we say that value he ain't
saying that value so you feed that money
a year afterwards it's probably still
difficult to find so they might have
gotten a decent amount now
my question is was grandma aware of
such the sale oh yeah no oh she knew you
knew you shouldn't show me
the parents don't approve i i i got the
same state grandma is down with it like
whatever
we're gonna sell this and she's like
okay cool you want me to say you know
how some parents do when they finally do
buy you something you keeping that joint
to it turn it
you know i'm sorry but like listening to
his grandma like she sounded like she
was hip she was down with this like all
right grabbing her in tune with them
seems like grandma seems like grandma
seems like the person you go to to buy
you that m rated gta when you ain't
supposed to oh absolutely absolutely
absolutely okay you see that's that's
what i'm talking about his grandma and i
grandma in tune
with all that you're selling them i
heard they were prostitutes in this game
no no i don't know what to talk about
grandma's time
uh we stuck with the 360 and i
absolutely love the 360. that's probably
one of my favorite consoles of all time
uh again things like mass effect on
there
huge um
you know uh halo obviously okay let me
ask you a question since y'all did all
the slander with the with the fable
which mass effect oh did you play all of
them right yeah i played all of them and
i played the legendary edition here we
go okay which mass effects in your
opinion is the best one uh it goes two
one three
two one three all
and when i replayed the legendary
edition it was actually way closer one
and two than i think you thought yeah
though i gave one a lot of credit
replaying i know solve yeah i i
slandered him a lot but whatever oh no
but but but again
this is why i asked because i really
wanted to hear his opinion on that
aspect of it because you know like okay
we have the fable thing i never had
anybody that was on the show that can
actually you know delve deep inside to
say you know that this fable or that fig
was better and i have my reasons for why
too was but we always have people on for
mass effect yeah so i just really wanted
to hear you appreciate that
and your opinion of it is pretty
accurate when you know i hear about it
so is your mass effect 3 opinion
solely based on kind of the ending stuff
yeah what is your three why is three not
the best
so the ending obviously isn't great but
i don't hate the end i've never hated
the ending nearly as much as anyone else
i don't i do not think it's like the
worst thing ever that anybody like makes
out to be but you don't have it at the
best
no no no for me three
i feel like they kind of dumbed down the
systems i really don't like these the
way they do uh like side quest
objectives in three compared to two
i liked two's quest logs so much more
three is like uh like go to this planet
pick up this item find some random
person in the citadel and drop it off to
them like
i i really didn't care for threes like
society's story because yeah requesting
because i one thing i love about mass
effect is the way it expands the world
like i did
i 100 it the legendary edition for one
and two and three was the only one i
didn't 100
i love those games okay uh and one the
only thing for two that brings it down
is i wish they kept a lot of the rpg
element like the pure rpg elements from
one yeah that's what i really like about
one i was like wow i i love how it felt
like a real rpg yeah no yeah let me let
me um switch gears for a second because
one thing we haven't brought up in your
gaming history that i've kind of as i've
been getting to know you we've been
interacting on social media and so forth
is and i think i could appreciate this
is we have this tremendous love for
turn-based games yeah you know what i'm
saying so i wanted to know about that
and any standouts from all these
generation games you played that you
were like yo these are your tournaments
because me and addy got awes but i'm
just curious about you what turn-based
games are some of the best for you
yeah turn uh turn-based games so uh fan
i don't know if anybody's played fancy
star three it was really what was really
good that's a card one i like card based
systems i think they're fun
but there's a lot of just
i think the gamecube is probably what
got me into like jrpgs which back then
traditionally were
turn-based games
a lot of the final fantasy games we're
we're turning based back obviously let's
do it since you touched that uh your
best final fantasy game sir
oh
uh well i have to i mean i have to say
seven remake is the best one okay um but
prior to remake prior to remake why to
remake uh well not 15 um
maybe 10 oh addict do we approve
it's okay yeah
i like you popped up
it's cool all right but what about this
what because i see slow ball in here and
it's off obviously a lot of a lot of six
fans
like um
are
the argument was six versus seven in its
original form where would you would you
pick over that in that argument uh i
never played six so okay
yeah i didn't i didn't those those
earlier ones
passed me by gotcha okay those are not
ones
people say who seven is not a remake
they didn't play it
we
final fantasy 10 is a really good game
though mm-hmm slo-mo is on martha man's
head ten sucks six
months
i'm a huge soccer fan so maybe
i feel like i feel like turn based for
me has been probably the last five years
i've really like dug into the turn based
like i've played a few back in the day
but more the last five years probably is
where i'm like wow turn-based games
really are hitting different these days
uh you know persona 5 royal i love fire
emblem
houses
those are great games
i'm excited for the new monarch game
that's coming out from the cree from the
old uh people from atlas so i don't know
something about turn based just appeals
to me more and yakuza like a dragon
which i think we talked about uh when
you were on my in my show
what what a game uh an absolute
gem of the game
um
but yeah there's i don't know no
tremendous history about that i mean i'm
actually gay
i feel like like a dragon is almost just
as good as persona five but oh yeah i
feel i agree with that so persona 5's
combat's just slightly better
i would agree with that yeah it's really
good i always feel for people who've um
probably knew the turn base that would
be a flashy one to kind of get them into
the systems and the cinematics and the
over the top nature of it it's kind of
like a feel-good fun game to kind of get
you in the turn base but yeah but good
choices man so you pretty much did the
last question i had before you gave me
before we move on is um
didn't hear a lot of playstation i want
to know um
if you had any of that no he said he
said ps5 was his first play that's right
so but no experience
of like the friend or you know seeing it
borrowing it
i so i had friends in high school most
of my friends were on the 360. but we
did have the the few select ones that
held our like playstation 3 is the best
so
we would go over and play on the
playstation 3's like you gotta check out
metal gear and i'd be like this
controller sucks
[Music]
to be
to be honest to be honest with you he's
the prime example of
you can go your whole life without being
playing playstation you'll be you'll be
just fine oh but y'all slander real life
he has he has some refined tape
ridiculous i truly i truly value his
opinion this is just
this is incredible so so by the way i
can't let you off like that hold on hold
on i guess man that he's our favorite
guy
he's on fire
we said it before dual sense first good
playstation controller oh my god guys
and and
that's not a lie
like that that's great okay because all
right
the way i love it he just had it
ironically right there
no no well i mean i don't have no
multiplayer um
right so
the triggers
for this thing they finally got the
triggers right for me right because
every time the
the triggers just never felt right but
the girth of it pulls um is actually
good and the nerves
feel tight and in control like i
actually really like this controller
like every aspect of the controller for
me is the best controller that they make
look i hear what y'all say with the
latest iteration but my question were
you a fighting games fan at all muffled
uh yes and i'm still a fighting game
okay
um
so
my dad was big and my dad was big into
tekken i didn't i didn't touch his
playstation i didn't touch his
playstation
that's why i asked you this question
because if you're a tekken fan and no
disrespect like i see where you go with
the xbox controller and i know where
you're going with the analog and the
offset i know in the first perk i get it
but if you're a fighting game fan
the playstation the separated d-pad was
the move for fighting and precise
um you know like animal like analog
movements fireball movements all that
stuff i just had to get that off because
i know yeah you're getting into my back
and i do like the xbox controller
overall better but i have to give sony
there rose with that i just want to
continue this story with yeah
and i i played tekken at a friend's
house um and he
mopped the floor with me i was like i
can't do anything with these how do i
move
um
yeah
my fighting game of choice back in the
day was smash brothers obviously and
then uh soul calibur
caliber so caliber main who was it oh
well i was i was lame so i i played link
because i had on the game yeah okay the
gamecube okay okay i remember this was
crazy
that was a an ingenious idea that they
came up with where you had spawned on um
on xbox yeah you had link and i think
link that that uh gamecube one was the
most sought after because oh yeah
actually able to play but that was
probably the most coveted one out of all
of them yeah yeah and uh what did sony
sony had
and he had like he had bands on so he
didn't have an actual weapon he had
bands on his hands that's what he had
yeah no doubt look you're right king
those are really great use of exclusive
platform characters yeah yeah continue
they've never crossed over and you
needed to have those consoles to play
those yeah
was it primal fury was that another one
was that the
gamecube fighting were you turned into
animals
that's what it is absolutely that bloody
roar thank you
love that game yeah great game um but
yeah anyway so we were on the 360. i
spent tons of times there and then i was
like oh the xbox one's coming out
everyone's like nobody wants tv and i'm
like yeah i don't i don't want tv
what do i need that for but but i was
team xbox so i was like i'm gonna grab
my xbox one and i
first off loved like launch day getting
that out of the big vcr i was like this
is i bought it first console i bought
with my own money i was like oh okay
level of price
drop the drop the 500 whatever i got it
set up and it was me and my brother both
did it
we were in college at the time was a
thousand dollars yes
we were in college and we were in the
dorm rooms and they said delivered and i
was like well where is it it's not in
the mail room oh hell no and it was
right
it was right before thanksgiving break
and i was like i ain't leaving this
campus without my xbox
got the delivery
so we we went to some administration
building we're like we know you got our
xbox right there and they're like you
gotta wait for wait for it to get you
i'm like nah wait and give me my socks
so they gave them over
so we set them up and then
you know what's funny he he's failing to
mention that you know they didn't give
it to him he he he pulled a heist man
he took action
at least at least they were in an
administration building they were people
that lost packages consoles as well when
i was in college they would lit they
would leave stuff outside of your dorm
room now
my the dorm that i was in this
particular time was a humongous dorm
that had multiple dorms within it so it
was just one big long hallway so
basically like anything they got left
there no cameras in the hallways they
were like yeah this package and then
anybody rooms are not locked oh no
but i saw people that had consoles and
stuff delivered never made it yeah
you said it was horrible man no no i
didn't know
i saw i saw people get some action
i don't know what you're talking about
that's horrible okay moving on
can't even lock your room up so someone
is a little late on the on that on that
you know those books theme man they they
just throw in any room and get the money
for those books
there's a reason why you had to put you
know ties on the door for stuff you know
you know you can't gotta let people know
continue
[Laughter]
and the first games i played were call
of duty ghosts which was the last call
of duty i ever played
yeah that game is an absolute i love the
story of that game i didn't even the
quick events yeah or whatever marios
centurions yeah this is lovely looking
good to this day yes
i yell form two lanes for no reason all
the time
[Laughter]
oh
so
during this time i graduate college
during this generation and
during this time i actually like kind of
got
out of gaming like i didn't really i
wasn't really that impressed with what
was coming out okay uh i was like i
don't really know if i'm gonna get the
next console i was like maybe it was
like a mix of depression or whatever
like post
post graduate life you know struggling
to get into the world whatever it was um
the standouts for me that jen were
hellblade which i think is an absolutely
phenomenal game uh celeste you know so
two games focusing on mental health so
maybe that's like you know my mindset at
the time
um and then the other one which
surprised people this is like the game i
put the most multiplayer hours into last
gen was uh was battleborn really
yes wow i
i think this game was criminally
underrated and people were like it's
it's just
competing with overwatch when in reality
it's a very different game to overwatch
i think i think part of the reason is
sometimes developers in the fan base
kill a game long before the game could
kill itself and would you come out
saying that we're the answer to
overwatch or your fans say that
like you're automatically being com
you're automatically competing with
overwatch before you can coming out so i
kind of like why you see no one say
we're the destiny killer anymore because
like you know you've killed your own
game that's had nothing to do with it
yeah yeah but battleborn for me was like
i like the characters way more i like
the actual multiplayer game modes i'm
not an overwatch guy i tried it i was
like i don't like this
um but so i was really sad to see that
die yeah and then i was like all right i
would play a few games here and there
you know fifa a lot a lot of last
channel stuck on fifa with me like
playing with friends it was just
something to do but i didn't feel like i
was really getting the most of the xbox
one like where were my stellar games
um and i think a lot of people felt that
way because i would log on and just see
people using it as netflix machines oh
damn
yeah
but
towards something happened towards like
the end of last gen and maybe it was
like the next gen hype where you know
microsoft started making all these moves
and game pass came in and i just i
started discovering i was like i'd go on
and be like oh i'm gonna play this game
and then it was really good i'm gonna
play this game it's really good and i
was like you know what i'm gonna i'm
gonna get the series x and i got i've
got it and i've had it since day one and
i absolutely i'm full in on gaming i
have been for the last two years i've
played 67 games this year wow uh a lot
on game pass obviously but
yeah
so
leading up to next gen though it was
like i was watching everyone's showcase
i was getting more into just listening
to podcasts like you guys and kind of
funny and
defining uh well not if i do about the
last media stuff over there and um
and i was like you know what i'm gonna
pay attention to playstation for for
once and see what they got going on and
i think the showcase that was like
i'm gonna buy playstation five was the
one where they showed off ratchet and
clank because being a nintendo kid
growing up i was like ratchet and clank
was always the one i was like man i wish
i could play that like yeah that was
what you missed out on yeah yeah like
that like that looks that looks fun so i
was like i'm gonna get it i'm gonna i'm
gonna do it
and then they're like pre-orders go live
tomorrow and then they went live 30
minutes later and i was like yeah what
is this why you lie to me
my brother woke up at 3 a.m got one on
best buy randomly that night and i was
like can you get me one
but
salute i yeah so i looked for a few
weeks but i was like i mean i want to
play ratchet and clank but so i have
both next-gen consoles nice
um
and yeah they've been great i clearly
spend more time on my xbox i've played
the i've played the exclusives
playstation that i missed out on last
gen that i wanted to do a lot of catch
up yeah yeah like i played god of war
which i think is great i played until
dawn because i
my horror games i like the walking
simulator oh
you're saying that
i'm not i'm not like a resident evil guy
like those guy i can't even play
resident evil 4. i tried back in the day
on gamecube and i was like it's too
scary let's give my brother the
controller
i'll feel that i'll feel it um
but
i kind of skipped a little chapter here
but apart from the next gen consoles um
in 2018 my friend's like you got to get
a switch
nintendo's back let's get a switch and i
was like guys i i really don't
really don't want to get us right i
don't i don't want to be apart
yeah i was like nintendo what have they
done that i've heard about the last
decade
and then
then my brother was like nah check this
out and he sends me the link for smash
brothers ultimate and was like they're
bringing everyone back and i was like
all right i'm going to buy a switch
so i went wayne got a switch
and then
the first in my opinion my first two
years with the switch so 2018 2019 were
great we got smash we got firearm
luigi's mansion astral chain which is
all fully underrated
sir you're good now you're back with me
yeah i don't understand why nobody likes
yeah
yeah fantastic game
uh
but since then since the end of 2019
since 2019 has been a little bit uh
my switch has been sitting in his dock
uh occasionally getting turned on for
some smash brothers and that's it i'm
like where are the games nintendo you
got nothing going on
so i'm i know people are like oh they've
had pokemon snap and metroid tread and
i'm like i ain't i ain't playing about
this like you said that metroid don't
move the needle oh not for me not for me
for me i told you he could come back any
day
well it's funny connecting with all of
us on certain specific days and stuff
and like we could go on this is this
tremendous history buffalo love love
hearing these stories and then obviously
talk about obviously getting the new
consoles and then kind of getting
reinvigorated then you start looking at
the podcast game look at what's going on
so i did want to transition to that
which is you know project x talk and um
obviously i was uh humbly invited and i
told you guys yeah i had a good time i
really really enjoying myself you know i
felt you guys kind of get in your
footing but you know now 50 about 57
episodes or so and um i want to shout
out your crew what is it lord lords
amman is it all tom and garrett yep okay
cool so uh give us the sales pitch tell
the realm
about project x talk and what can we
expect and what inspired you guys to
create it
yeah so it was kind of um we didn't know
each other like at all um i
kind of was like looking i was like you
know what i want to get into the the
content creation scene the podcast scene
because i'm listening to everyone i was
like i would love to have these
conversations with people and just even
if we don't have that many listeners
just just interact with some more people
than i am currently because like my
friends are into gaming my brother's
probably the biggest one but like they
don't look at it at the industry level
and and you know analyze things like
like i was into so i went on reddit and
amman was actually looking for like a
he's like anybody looking to make a
podcast you know i'm really looking to
to find some people so he he hit up me
garrett and tom
and then it found out that tom is
actually from upstate new york as well
we're like 30 minutes away from each
other building let's go yeah you already
know home team home state
yeah so tom and i have really connected
obviously you know living really close
to each other um and then amman's in the
uk and garrett's in canada
so
yeah
but we we came together we were like
okay what do we want the show to be and
we can i kind of came up with a tag you
know everyone pretends to be like
insiders and journalists it's like let's
let's say you know we're we're not
journalists but we pretend to be like a
kind of a joke of what everyone else is
doing in in the scene
so we're like
what's a what's like what's the most
important thing and i think the
community is really the most important
thing and for me that's kind of what i
want our show our our main podcast to be
is where we reach out to people like
yourself we've had uh you know uh luke
lauren slipping ghost mr bad bit uh matt
from fun special
fun speculation we got mr boomstick
coming on this weekend
i just i like connecting with everyone
else that's like in the community and
bringing people on and seeing like who
we can talk to what their experiences
are um chris cornell i think was a we
had him on you guys i know you had them
a few weeks ago
absolutely one of my favorites just like
hearing and learning
because it's it's stuff like
hearing it's one thing actually talking
to someone is like a whole different
experience
and it's something like i never really
thought that i would be able to
experience like talking to an ex sony
dev like out yeah sweet two years ago
that's never gonna happen like i'm never
gonna talk to these people they're in
some fantasy land
um
but we're all like big xbox fans so we
kind of were like let's focus on the
xbox ecosystem because xbox was like
and is currently like the the talk of
the town almost like game passes ron and
riot everyone's really big in in xbox so
i like that one reference that was
smooth continue
very stupid i like that
[Laughter]
so that's where we focus um our our
channel and we've been going for about a
year now you know we've had like
30-something guests which is out of
50-something episodes is it's crazy to
me that people are so willing to give
like a small smaller like a small
podcast a chance and come on and and
really just talk and like connect and no
one has ever like looked down and be
like you only got this many songs i
don't know let me get you have people
speak to your people and i get back to
you next year
unfortunately you keep it up man you'll
run into them eventually
salute brother now i mean i want to
shout you out because again you know we
tried you know me and addict had this
conversation before and you know trying
to give up and coming content creators
of voice we know how it was for us and
like i said i don't like the bs people
like you know i try to make myself
available as much as i can obviously my
schedule's crazy but when you did reach
out and i remember doing the show and i
told you guys after the show i was like
yo you guys got a good podcast i really
did enjoy myself so um definitely salute
to you and keeping the journey going but
there is one last question here for the
buff of mine that we have to get to and
me and king
and saul
i've been very pleased we've been very
patient
we have to know what is the whole
history behind this name what is the
significance is it muffin monster like
what's going on with the muffin mom what
is this dave about
so
uh you know back in back in my youth uh
i was quite the uh the chubby kid i was
i was very large
and in college one of my favorite things
to eat was uh was muffins i would get
like two muffins a day at a tim hortons
over there tim horton muffins
now i understand bro
i used to i used to share a gamer tag
with my brother um but then when we got
older and we we split our our consoles
are like okay i need my own gamertag
what what's what is my brand gonna be
i was like well what do i what do i like
and it's like i like muffins
big you know fat kid mentality right
there
so i was like i'm just gonna be the
muffin man i was like that's a little
funny but it's taken oh somebody
you would not believe the amount of
muffin mans i've run into
i was like listen there could be only
one
you're gonna you're gonna fight me on
this
but i was like all right i'm gonna try
some different spellings and then i
ended i i decided on mon because i was
like i like pokemon digimon like i was
big into that i was like let's go with
man it sounds it sounds kind of so it's
not it's nothing like it basically comes
from me being a fat kid and loving
muffins i love it
i thought he was gonna say
muffin man came from he was like you
know what they you know since you know
jamaica
[Music]
shout out to embarka he said
them
yes yes to you
you know how your brain goes and
the muffin man is here
i don't know if i i don't know if i'm
allowed to pretend to be jamaican
i said one day we're gonna have to have
like a tournament all the muffin man's
it can only be one there could only be
ones
so i see a lot of canadian flags
[Music]
what's up probably for tim hortons
probably
yeah i know i uh i've kept that for
everything i use it on basically all
social media um my smash brothers tag is
muffin so like i'm carrying it over like
you ain't getting rid of the muffin yo
salute
for owning it running with it and it's
like yo this is me you don't say a
salute to you man that's tremendous i
love the game history love all that
stuff so we got to ask you that question
that we ask all those in the realm i
need lord muffinmon's top five video
games or franchises of all time
uh okay we got mass effect
trilogy obviously um we have
halo 2 specifically i like all i like
well i like all the halos except for i
don't like four i know people
i know people like you like five but not
four you like five more i like five
better than four wow this is that's a
spicy take i know like me and luke laura
went back and forth on it yeah well i
can tell you guys probably about to get
off your podcast right at that moment
are you like a huge multiplayer person
with halo or um
i mean i play them more for the story
co-op so you liked halo 5.
i
hate the enemies in halo 4 i think is
really like i i don't know i struggled
to even play the single player and maybe
it was like maybe it was because the it
was the only one you're like fighting
the same dude four times
just just bring up just bring up fable
again i said you'll be fine
you know you know what it might be is
that
four was the only one i played solo i
didn't play co-op oh so the other quad
had a positive influence on your this
okay okay probably
get the chance to do that [ __ ]
you don't get a chance to do
i'm i'm implying that he's pretty cool
with that five i'm down with him
you're right you're a five there's a
reason for that that's why
it's a reason why you'd be wrong a lot
so i'm listening to him right now he's
back in the thousands we own this too
you got some wins with him let me have
the facts back let's go i got to let him
speak it's true i just wanted him to
explain himself that was all five is
where is that okay cool so we got bass
effect trilogy on
i think that was the best story of any
of any halo game
that's when everything possible it was
great it was okay
he was okay with the orbiter he was okay
oh yeah i
uh number three will be the tales of
series the jrpg tales of arise is
amazing
um
then we would have
super smash brothers
that's my big i played melee
endlessly and i played i've played
ultimate probably total two thousand
hours and i compete in tournaments
so oh yeah yeah so i i go to i go to
smash tournaments uh up here in in
upstate new york thank you oh
tournaments
do you play with the pro controller or
do you play with the um
a little switch jump off i played the
pro
i played with the pro controller because
i i so gamecube controller while i loved
it back in the day and i know most smash
people play with it after playing on the
xbox for 12 years or whatever it's like
my hands aren't going back to the game
it's it's fine uh but pro controller is
completely
completely fine for smash brothers and i
mean do i win these tournaments no my
highest place is eighth that's right bro
that's still good come on i got a little
graphic twitter
you're playing with people just as good
or better than like bro we always
minimize that you put it up on the line
salute to you on that when you're oh
yeah yeah anytime you start yeah anytime
you step up yeah we from that yeah
salute to you only ice climber main in
upstate new york i'm gonna throw that
out there okay
have yet to find another ice climber
maine
that plays in tournaments like i do i
always liked ice climber because like
one was just like pretty much
like it wasn't relevant so as long as
you were able to i think it was the the
the uh brother that you throw off and it
would it was the brother wouldn't it uh
the nana nana's dead
yeah because if you throw one of them
off it will kill both of them but if you
only if you throw the other one off the
uh the the other one will still live
that's crazy yeah yeah yeah so so smash
uh mainly melee and ultimate uh brawls
garbage uh didn't play four uh
slam it
and then i would end with uh my boy here
let me just let me just get him uh
banjo-kazooie
is he got the goat guest for you right
now
yeah besides the halo 5 thing
i like the multiplayer halo 5 i just did
wouldn't fill my single player mm-hmm
sell us a banjo why tell tell speak loud
for cole eastwood if he's listening
yeah yeah i'm a huge 3d platforming fan
and banjo for me is like the game that
got me into that genre and when he was
coming to smash brothers i went and
played replayed banjo on my xbox i was
like this game holds up this game is
fantastic so i really like the
renaissance kind of that we're getting
of 3d platformers you know ratchet we
got psychonauts 2 which is phenomenal
yes absolutely phenomenal those
collect-a-thon style games which we
probably saw more of back at like the
ps2 era i really love that they're kind
of making a comeback now and we're
getting those but for me banjo is is the
goat in that in that area so
and i've always felt
give me a remake
i've always felt like
banjo is such a good icon that if they
would put money behind i honestly do
feel like it would be you know just as
big as something like ratchet and clank
no doubt no doubt silly angry yeah they
with your backhand sides but you foster
really got the thumb down
he hate the bad boy
cool so
some someone needs to get fawns riley up
out of here
nah we gotta get dude
radio gtr coming up we got to kick him
up but look man and the last one i think
i know the answer to this but we have to
ask it favorite console of all time and
why
um
right now i have to say the 360 because
it had the best gaming experiences on it
uh it's it really kind of i mean they
revolutionized the controller game first
of all they brought in the the one that
we've kind of got iterations on but you
had those stellar
triple a 10 out of 10 titles hidden all
the time and it just really brought us
into like the online multiplayer
experience
in my opinion for sure
maybe the series x eventually and first
year has been great in my opinion but
series x is on its way no no no i'm with
you there like it's funny you said that
because i'm with you i'm with peter
morgan i'm a 360 guy king knows how i
know how he feels about phil how would
you feel about phil but i i do feel
like
siri's ex look like he's shaping up to
be potentially something
like to remember for the ages
dudes ain't gonna recover from this
fight
had to keep it funky
the layup the layup they messed up the
layer with that xbox one they messed it
up don chi-chi messed it up
i'm gonna tell you right now phil is
like a rabbit pit bull he ain't gonna
let you go the fight's over let's just
lay down and stay down
[Music]
of my salute
gave me this three man that was fire
brother honestly i don't know if you're
tired of straight but you were born and
welcome the heck out through the topics
we're not kicking you out yeah just want
to be yeah okay
i got my schedule's cleared mommy
just what a big shot because i did
forget to ask you that brian dude i'm
like i didn't ask for that but it's a
little bit so you're gonna get a chance
to hang out so if you want to get the
super chat song or you want me to do the
poll and then do the paul then i'll do
the super chats and then we have a
little special yes some some no doubt no
doubt and of course last week's poll
results in the people have spoken with
the recent exceptional reviews of forza
horizon 5 on open critic and metacritic
do you think a racing game should be in
contention for game of the year
at the game awards the winner of the
poll at a dominant 82 percent of the
vote
was yes quality games must be respected
regardless of genre group coming in at
second place at 50 of the vote was the
messi laws i don't care about game of
the year i thought xbox a had no games
though
that last place and only two percent of
the vote was no racing game should have
their own category like multiplayer
games since they lack a major narrative
group i see the muffin man shaking his
head very strongly uh what did you feel
about the the realms voting did you do
you agree
uh for surprise and five is the first
shorts i've ever played and it's it's
great i i'm really i'm really liking way
more than way more than i thought um i'm
not the open world guy i don't like when
i open the map and see a bunch of
checklist things to do but for forza i'm
like i'll go race i'll go race my i just
like getting my car going fast it's
beautiful i definitely think it deserves
to be in the conversation okay fair
enough fair enough lord sub you want to
get a these uh chat sir yes sir okay no
we got it
i know it's a lot yeah it wasn't that
many no it seemed like it was but we got
we got gerald mack five thousand chat oh
hell the iop salute the iop podcast are
part of the pantheon of content creators
in the community salute lords thank you
my brother little brother always showing
love
then we got don otaku 10 super chat
fable one is definitely the best fable 2
was more cinematic had better combat a
bigger scale of conflict but the end
just fell flat for me fable one just had
better systems and pay off with choices
you need it more wise
[Laughter]
and concurring with with king is a mass
erect
super chat
king was spreading his crystal d
jesus
then we have crystal d with the two
dollars wait what we got somebody to
roam name
[Music]
there was no spread time
what is happening
we have this entire
super chat narrative going on here i
love this
the fact he named himself that is out of
pocket yeah we have
then we have slow mo back slap two
dollars over that seed spreading is
greater than good
[Laughter]
i
antagonism
that fable section with left
then we have splendiferous wow two
dollar super chat mikasa sukasa got that
all natty oil for your girl whoa
what is going
this
we blaming king for his fatal remarks on
this
was about their life it's his story he's
making his story in favor
of it
alex
shout out to actually scores a member
for three months shout out to you
shout out to mass effect 3 for letting
me scan skip walking and
skip walking around dead lifeless
planets yeah okay
i was that was smart then we got big
cloud gaming shout out to big cloud the
homie remember for nine months salute to
the realm keep doing y'all thing much
love is always your boy gotta dip and
get back on this project stay safe my
brothers big cloud doing a little bit
i love what he's doing the guests the
ign spot bro it's a little bit crowded
he's doing it the right way
i'm so proud of him man salute to the
whole yeah hustling for sure then we
have uh let's put the crest in the chat
for necromancer zale big shout out to
you sir
let me see
anything else let me roll back and i
think we're good all right let me get
the merch looks like a bunch of
anonymous so i just got to shout you out
um you got the
lettered pull over salute to you
somebody got a little van okay little
van full over hoodie no doubt somebody
got the all natty another daddy king on
the black tee oh shout out somebody got
the classic 10k pull over to 10k just so
y'all know this is the new 10k joint
logo right there yeah king's got it on
there you go so y'all see the two 10k is
up there oh you don't have to see this
one in somebody but the who did that for
you
who did that for you we haven't seen
that in a minute somebody cop that
t-shirt [ __ ] jay bought a pint glass
love the show fellas king yeah sorry
you're gonna have to send me two of
those pint glasses
get the pint glasses yeah [ __ ] j pink
he said that lovely shirt was king get
him anonymous got a classic tee of
little man um shout out to zayle i
believe classic t oh king the first
reason he got the aurelius oh dreams
keep up the great work that'll be the
new one we're working on the arm icon
and all that stuff just if more members
we get the more icons we can have so
that we are all caught up so let's get
it over man attic man wait wait wait
wait oh yeah oh my god i'm gonna do them
and do this you do your thing baby do
your thing big shout out to cog and the
powers that that be um
we were blessed with a nice little code
for writers republic on the pc i believe
it's through the ubisoft launcher itself
so it's a pretty cool
for the ultimate edition for writers
republic now writer's republic is kind
of the the spiritual sequel to steep so
it has you know extreme games a lot of
snowboarding and stuff so i'm going to
ask a question to the chat mm-hmm
the first p person to answer this
correctly will get this code
so the question is since we're talking
xbox 20th anniversary here
at the launch of the original xbox
the original xbox og xbox there were two
snowboarding games that launched one on
launch day one a few days later one was
one was exclusive one wasn't
one was good one was bad
what are the names of those two
snowboarding games that launched on
launch day of the xbox the original xbox
and one also launched a few days later
maybe four days later so they both
launch a window two snowboarding games
one bad one good what are they what are
they
no
no no
no
okay somebody got one right
okay
shout out to flaming nope nope
nope nobody's getting that second
snowboarding game that was
you know
you know what um
i felt like that game was missing when i
was playing it
i don't know why but like snowboarding
games have like i like that that mode
where you can like do a 1080 avalanche
thing where like there's an avalanche
behind you shout out to the last
broadcaster
dark sound of it and
it was a great game it was exclusive to
the xbox but did not launch day and date
it was a few days later dark summit
launched on multiple consoles and it was
not well received so shout out to
broadcasters lad broadcaster hit me up
on my dms lord saab iop on twitter i
will get to that code sir
congratulations no doubt no doubt salute
man good that's a good one it's off i
like that yeah
darks i i remember i purchased dark sun
yes
shout out to all you copy and paste
warriors thought she was gonna be ready
you had to do homework everybody
everybody was quick
so yeah i'm about to get this i'm about
to play this no what
let's get into it we got these topics to
get into alex we're going to kick it off
with you
halo infinite a lot of stuff going on
ign first i believe game informa
exclusive preview coverage and um also
we got to talk about some potential
rumors on multiplayer what's going on
with halo that you hearing
so apparently you know let's go with the
campaign first
ig got their first uh look uh halo
infinite campaign i really recommend
everyone go over there and watch
miranda's coverage on it like like she
did a really good job you can like
really feel the energy coming off when
she made this video you could tell she's
a real big fan of the franchise itself
uh you don't want to go over
you know what was said and all of these
uh all these previews and apparently you
know it's been
covered by a lot of outlets here
recently but it's rumored that you know
maybe
halo infinite's multiplayer jumps before
the single player
i want to hear kings first on this okay
i got a confession to make i think i
like it yeah i do
i think king and i are in the same boat
all right so wait this is beta boy stuff
i got a yeah yeah i know i know i know
this is better but i knew this was gonna
happen because
king is not going to want any of that
spoiled nope so king is going to stay
away from that he's considering that
preview bit all that's better
no no no dude you don't know where this
confession oh my bad sorry okay oh no no
he's on the other side of it now no no
let me confess my soul get this dirt off
of me let's go
i've played battlefield 20.
yeah okay so now okay you want to talk
about that no i'm not watching the video
[Laughter]
all right um no and i love miranda yes
you know and i think she's fantastic i
love all of her work and i just
truly support everything that she does i
will watch it after i play the campaign
okay you know i that's that's what i
live and breathe for i live and breathe
for the halo campaign you know these
dudes be out capping for this
multiplayer i'm playing a test flight
but you were just 10 out you was
throwing it up for 10 hours but that
today between the hours of seven and
five
you'll be able to fly with us like why
is it called test flight first of all
that turns me off completely like
it's a test flight hmm who came up with
this idea because that means we can
crash and fail right this is what this
is possible so i was like no i don't
want to be any parts of this but
i'm waiting to get my hands on that
complete
story and you know i'm people trying to
spoil stuff for me little by little man
buddy copping dip me white and i'm just
like get off my timeline telling me
about what's going on because i don't
suffer with fomo
i don't suffer with that and i don't
want to hear how somebody else's
experience with something that i love
should make me just
i want to watch them play hell no
[Laughter]
like at no point in time am i'm sitting
there cheering you on because you're
playing the game i want to play ah
that's crazy as hell but i don't i don't
get it i don't understand it i'm not a
fan of it but these dudes is out here
like yo did you see the elden ring thing
and i'm like why would i do that to
myself unless the game is out like why
would i touch that oh did you see
somebody's review
did they eat your food and give it back
to you baby bird like did you do you
like it like that so i don't care for
that i don't want that but i hear about
the multiplayer being dropped and i said
yo
i know what's gonna happen what do you
think about the multiplayer drops in
this totality is a free-to-play game
it's an actual game
we're all gonna group up we're all going
to have a great time right i can do that
all right but i'm not being
let's see
my thing is uh muffin man
you may not know i don't feel i feel
that you're supposed to get paid
for doing work for these companies right
and if microsoft is doing this or sony's
doing this or nintendo's doing this this
free labor and you're getting our data
and you're testing this this stuff out
at the um
like the flights you you're testing the
servers out you're testing to see if the
stress can it can withstand the stress
or what guns work better in what
scenarios
people got paid for that stuff back in
the days
right so
i would like to see everybody that
participated in these test flights get a
free skin exclusive skin exclusive
warthog something something cosmetic to
show that thank you for participating
not a slap on the back like good guy
thank you we did great numbers um but
you're getting paid y'all actually
getting checks so these guys are
actually doing the hard work and then
you have
guys like us that will come up and say
oh yo so i did the test flight this
weekend that's free promotion that's
free marketing
again we're on this end of doing the
free stuff just because we're fans and
you're using our fandom against us and i
don't appreciate that we've been on your
square with that for the month
battlefield i didn't play that but even
though it's a field game it's cool it's
cool but what about what you think man i
mean obviously these halo infinite
previews are out on like i said i just
first i believe game informer and then
your thoughts on that and then also
you know what are you thinking about
these potential rumors of a of a stealth
drop
of multiplayer yeah so i i didn't watch
miranda's video i read her article i
ain't watching i i'm going i'm going
blind oh you're doing the gig okay okay
i told you i love this guy he could come
back any day he like i don't want to see
i don't want to see more halo don't show
me story beats don't show me nothing
like okay i want to i'll read she did a
great write-up though like when i when i
when i read it the one thing that stuck
out to me was her describing how it's
not like a full open world experience
and more like how the levels are gonna
work that really was like okay those
alleviated my worries that this is gonna
be like far cry 6 type
game play where i'm like i don't really
like that um i know some people do but
that's not what i want from halo i like
a lower she's like it starts out more
linear and then it slowly opens up into
like these optional objectives but
they're not fetch quests so
miranda thank you for alleviating my uh
my concerns there yes um
she you know she touched on how there's
named boss battles which i think we all
kind of all kind of knew that's that's
going to be a cool change i think in
terms of the multiplayer dropping
tomorrow i saw that tweet from nate the
yeah
he tweeted a few hours ago he's like
11th hour change they're not going to do
it tomorrow and i'm like well were they
ever going to do it i don't really i
don't know who you are
so
for me
i'm like that would be awesome that
would be a great surprise it would
really be like celebrate in 20 years
what better way than with halo
do i think they're going to do it
maybe probably not if i'm being honest
let me ask you this because i've seen
this talk going around on twitter as
well in regards to the multiplayer drop
let's just say hypothetically they do it
right okay so
i've also seen some conversations that
people say it's a mistake
because even though they're taking
advantage of the uh the 20th anniversary
that
it would be stealing forza horizon 5's
thunder what's your thought on that
debate going on i'm seeing right now i
don't agree i think it's i think it's a
lot of
there are people that play halo that
have no interest in forza and forza has
what eight million players now it's
doing crazy numbers it was like seven
yesterday or something last i heard um
it's absolutely blowing up and it's
getting people that have no interest in
forza like me to actually play the game
but people there are people that have no
interest in forza and they're just
waiting for halo so i think both can
exist i don't see why we have to
especially because it's free
[Laughter]
it's not like i have to choose i don't
have to choose that's a good point yeah
but okay just to the counter point right
to that
um the fact that it's inside game pass
uh do you feel that being that they're
both there like you said they're both
free you don't have to actually like buy
them right
per se right but you know we do buy them
you know people think we don't buy games
but
we actually do
um
but the fact that they're inside game
pass
that split engagement we see in like
record numbers for forza do you think
that will cannibalize it because it's in
game pass and it will pull engagement
because we don't know the metrics
on
the actual sales of forza right right
but we know the metrics on the
engagement aspect of it right so placing
uh halo at this point inside that uh
ecosystem
where a game is rising and we don't know
its peak yet because it hasn't start uh
descending yet so it's just ascending
would halo cannibalize it in that sense
of pulling engagement from that current
group because we're looking at probably
what what 30 31 million in game pass so
we haven't reached the peak of it yet uh
the death solver yeah i noticed that
right that's higher and higher
and you know it's hot you know you
notice how much i ignored it yeah
meet you in that bag now we just like
let him go
[Laughter]
to
i think for sure some we will see less
time played in forza because there are
people that are going to
drop out to go play halo and they can
play both but it's not like oh i'm only
going to play forza for four hours
tonight i'm gonna play forza for two and
halo for two right so if they're looking
at those metrics of engagement then yeah
forza is gonna go down but the player
base i think will still be strong in
both regardless
i think it's more important to keep
people playing games in the xbox
ecosystem
rather than keeping people playing forza
like all these games coming out now
people are going to start jumping over
to battlefield to call of duty to
fortnite it's better to have them jump
from forza to halo then have them jump
from forza to call of duty and
battlefield where they might not play
halo next month
it's a good one um yeah i'll jump i'm
sorry jumping i didn't get sold what am
i doing so you thought you were about to
confess about something as well and then
no i wasn't confessing about anything i
was just i was surprised at kingdom but
i get it you know it's part of game pass
it's the 10-hour play thing yeah i get
it i get it i get it so he he's he's
still he's still good he's all brained
[Laughter]
well you know what i didn't do i didn't
fraud and put myself on invisible yeah
yeah yeah i think the smoke somebody
screen shot at me i was in trouble
i mean but i'm in the same boat like
shout out to ryan mccaffrey shout out to
miranda sanchez i know the coverage is
fantastic yeah all i needed to hear was
it's good yeah you're good okay okay i
turned everything off i'm like i'm good
i don't want to see it again in terms of
in terms of the story in terms of
campaign i don't want to see it i don't
want to know how it plays out i don't
even want to know the the cadence of i
don't want to know any of that okay i
i'm going to experience that day one um
you on brand right now that's classic
that that was for me when it comes to
the halo story like this is where you
and your brother
literally differ because kakbatsu will
be like oh what's going on
but i want to know everything i'll be
like yo the last boss is this i'm like
damn
yeah
that's the type of stuff that gets you
kicked out there i can't wait we don't
do that
now
i'll just go out for you so the
multiplayer stuff
is interesting to me because i i'm i'm
of the mind just like muffin man
believes that
it's all in game pass i don't think it
cannibalizes one
each other right right normally
i don't think that happens because it's
just it's all in there you just you play
whenever you want it's all quote unquote
free or whatever it's all you're paying
for it already right now
the thing that kind of gives me a little
pause here is
that
i just didn't think
forza horizon 5 would be doing what if
you're doing yeah that changes the game
that good points
really like what's happening with forza
horizon 5 on a grand scale is special
when you have people who don't play
racing games playing it for the first
time saying wow i get what everyone's
talking about and the fact that it is
that accessible that anybody could jump
in and play it and enjoy it
it's it's more than just a racing game
remember i told you guys a couple weeks
ago once the really start coming out
we're gonna start seeing the hyper the
greatest racing game of all time and i
saw that talk a lot so to me it's like
this is getting a special kind of pop
that i think that if you if you had told
me halo's just coming out november 15th
and we were all excited and waiting for
it and ready for it i don't think it
takes away as much from from from forza
as a surprise drop tomorrow talking
about hey all of a sudden the
multiplayer is ready to go totally so
soft so fire i'm so sorry to catch so
you're i have to throw this in because
you're
do you think
because we've heard the history of forza
horizon right yes xbox themselves
didn't expect that game to be what it is
that franchise i remember people like
who wants this arcadey ford's uh open
world whatever then it takes off we're
gonna say peak maybe forza horizon 3 was
probably when people really really took
notice the australia setting they were
like oh wow it really took off so now
if what mafimon is saying the rumor is
true about the you know
i love that i love that yeah i love it
and i love the whole connotation i'll be
saying it all day now so the whole thing
is like yeah it's kind of behind the
rumor where
there may be an audible pulled in the
11th hour and say yo
we might be messing up a moment
because now i'm seeing the chat somebody
said eight million players you know king
is making good points about maybe
crossing game if there is an audible
pulled do you think it could be like yo
maybe we do need to let this magic and
then the reviews right but continue i
just have to get it off i absolutely
believe that i think again it's one of
those things this is your fifth horizon
game right so you expect the people to
love it to love it you expect the
quality to be there because from the
first one to quality just only improve
but it's always been great
and it's just it's a moment where
everybody was ready for it game is in
more hands than ever before yeah
all of a sudden you have people like i'm
just going to try this game i don't play
racing games at all i'm just going to
try this game
and there's plenty of people who just
put this game on and out and are not
worried about races they're just running
around the world seeing things crashing
into into boards and stuff like that and
having a great time
this is i believe a moment that we when
you talk about forza having a real
chance of winning game of the year
i think it does have a really really
real chance of winning it because it is
to me it is the most polished version of
this formula ever seen
and on top of that it's it doesn't need
the narrative stuff because it's
engaging to everybody if you don't know
i forgot who it was i saw a video of oh
i know a man of a man who set up his um
his daughter
his daughter right in the wheelchair
that was beautiful and she's she was
playing for the horizon
and it's just like beautiful thing
there are so many ways to engage with
this game
that it is it's a special moment and i
think i hope microsoft recognizes that
i understand dropping halo infinite
multiplayer 20th anniversary song i've
got all the feels the history of xbox
i say
don't don't do it
don't do it
because
what you think you might get let's see
we always have a problem with microsoft
not doing things organically right right
sony has been the organic champion
supposedly but they have allowed stuff
to go organically right they allow stuff
to breathe
give it its space right let's see
exactly what it actually can become
could you imagine
if they let it go they don't drop the
halo and by next friday they double the
number from 18 i mean from eight to 16.
that'd be crazy let's have some crazy
some crazy forza centric announcement
for tomorrow so tomorrow too but let me
play let me play
let's go corporate kingdom
right right now king you on fire with
that i feel you right but let's just say
internally let's let's just say back
when this was announced they said okay
it's gonna hit
well maybe they they had like modest to
the four to five million or whatever
internally that they thought they might
do they're like it's another four yeah
exactly it's another four we're going to
do well but this is zeitgeist well this
is like yo
we're stopping the internet everyone's
saying this is the definitive racing
game whatever
jason ronald was on jason was on ilp
and literally said the game he shot to
the cops they excited too they the like
the game that he is most excited for was
that game that he hadn't shot the attic
with the amazing question but the
question i have for boardroom king
is let's say they were hedging their bet
and let's say they go yo
november that financial quarter you know
we really need to knock it out the park
because technically halo misses it hits
into that december range right so maybe
they was like well we're going to miss
out on that big holiday season so maybe
we do that november drop we maybe do an
early access kind of campaign deal for
combining it just to you know anybody
who's a game pack what if they do like a
marketing push to try to get people in
so they could get that holiday
stockholder up money what'd you think
okay so i would say no okay okay because
all right so right now you have eight
million eyeballs on your ip right now
right yes eight million eyeballs
people would kill for that some some
people this i i would love to have eight
million eyeballs on the game that you
know that you see this engagement it's
happening
now let's say
you stage an event
inside the horizon world because that's
how the game is structured that you can
drop shadow drop events i did something
the other day that i was in an event and
we always in the same area circling
around waiting for the event to start
why don't you do a halo themed event
being that they have warthogs in there
and everybody that actually engages at
this point in time gets the warthog for
free with the new halo logo on it halo
infinite logo on the the warthog and you
see guys doing jumps and doing that's a
way to promote halo but also right now
yes that's what i'm saying it's there
but i'm saying give it for free for that
event if you participate in this event
on the on the 15th on our 20th
anniversary you still incorporate halo
right but you also take this ip
further yeah yeah by making the
engagement numbers like because people's
like what they have an event right now i
can get a warthog what are you crazy
push the fomo push them inside that that
that ecosystem in that area because i
feel if you put halo in then you have
the choice
right yeah then we won't ever really
truly know exactly what this game can
truly be
left alone to breathe
true marketing will fight for this title
being going ascending because it's not
descending it's ascending put more jet
fuel behind it to push it past the
stratosphere push it up there if pause
if you feel
that halo is the catalyst to what you
want to talk about later on to push that
that ip put some halo-centric stuff in
the game that actually has eight million
eyes on it okay no this is good this is
good i'll get i'm sorry sorry i get it
i'm sorry no no but but
and the thing is that this is the moment
this is the game to do it because i
don't care how amazing for forza
motorsport is it's and it's probably
going to be amazing yeah it's not going
to have this yeah all right can we
definitively say horizon has surpassed
motorsport yes yes horizon yeah as the
as the main quote as the casual for the
franchise is going to appeal to everyone
yeah yeah this is it okay
look let me you know make it fantastic
points um you know i'll start again
shout out to ryan moran i try to keep it
limited because on what you saw in the
reference of i don't want to get too
deep but the thing that excited me the
most that they did say that i liked was
that they both came in with very
nervous
expectations
based on muffin mods favorite halo 5
that i didn't particularly like to
campaign at all but salute to him he's
one of the riders out here salute to you
but you know they were they was they
were very adamant about that like yo
what do you expect and then you know
they each played individual then they
kind of met up and was like what did you
think because ryan was like yo i am
loving it you know what i'm saying and
um you know miranda the same thing so
i'm loving it i'm loving the the
combination it doesn't feel like the
full
on you know like like my family was
saying like ubisoft kind of formula kind
of thing it's kind of like it looks it
feels like a healthy balance so i'm
looking forward to see what's going on
i'm not going to dive too deep with that
this multiplayer thing is crazy because
i've been hearing it i said it on duke
you know people writing in i only spoke
on it because people were writing in
and we heard about it my only thing was
just okay what's the mentality
for doing it for stealth dropping
a multiplayer you know
full because i tried to give the out
i'm like the flight right
not the full
multi no no no they like to fall so
everyone's running with it the thing
that's interesting though
is microsoft has not jumped out in front
to shut this down like every major
outlet now is literally running with
this right then we got people looking at
pringles chips and showing pringles got
something in their database that line up
with the chip and on the same date at
the 15th with halo and what's going on
right so my i'm conflicted because
i'm with king
that
this forza moment is something different
i didn't expect all of this i was like
it's going to be a good forza but what
i'm seeing
from the the reaction the engagement the
thing like people are showing me clips
are jumping over people are talking
about my driving tall and twitter all
day
like it's super lit right now so it it
is interesting you know if maybe this
new rumor that we're seeing that maybe
there's a last minute audible a
last-minute pull back because maybe they
say yo
we gotta let forza have this and then
they have the month of november december
comes and then boom so
is is it just a very i don't know where
this is going to go all i know is
tomorrow's going to be late regardless
of whatever time is that 1 p.m eastern 1
p.m
i mean i guess when it comes to the
multiplayer for me
i don't think that
it's dropping in december i think if
anything they might push it back a week
and have it sometime like the 20th 21st
like
i don't think they're gonna wait till
december i think it's going to come out
earlier you're still going to think the
[ __ ] i think that they'll
announce the date tomorrow
but it won't be out tomorrow i guess the
only confusion i have y'all is
this game
has been phil has been on record
statement has been on record
the multiplayer and the campaign are
going to be launched together as one
unit
right they've been animate because i
remember ryan asking phil when he had
fell on and was like yo could you ever
drop the bow tie player early
you know nope coming together complete
pat so i'm just my men test is like i'm
not listening if it drop i'm playing i'm
not mad
i'm in there but i'm just saying i was
just trying to understand what changed
prior to this forza announcement affords
it being great and you know doing what
it's doing to them thinking yo we gotta
do it and the only thing is maybe it was
the boardroom at one point and said yo
let's not hit y'all bet if forza don't
hit we drop it maybe now fours are
hitting way crazier than they thought
and maybe now they pull it but tomorrow
gonna be lit i'm dying to know
what the hell happens but that's all i
got attic you got anything on your topic
for you before i think when it comes
down to it
i think that their mentality is
i think they honestly want the campaign
and the multiplayer to be judged
separately and i think that their
mindset is if we put them together
they're not going to be judged
separately and and they have came out
multiple times and saying that you know
this game's coming out together
and i think that they would get a little
bit of backlash but as long as it
doesn't get delayed if it gets pushed up
i don't think they're going to get a lot
a lot of backlash i think some people
might say
you know why aren't they coming together
but i think the majority of people say
okay this is a free to play so it's okay
if i get it a week early right or you
know a week and a half early yeah i
think that
they want the reviewers to get enough
time to
play the multiplayer as its own and then
two weeks later they dropped the
campaign
and then they get their own time to play
that individually and not play them
together where they have to to consider
them both
because technically these are two
different games it's like gta online and
gta 5 right they're two different games
now and i think
microsoft's probably in that mindset
that we need to treat them like two
different games
i got one question before move on yes so
removing forza from the equation um
what about the idea that dropping it now
puts a dent into battlefield
what
so confusing because battlefield right
obviously you know there's no game pass
you're not dropped in but you do have
that sort of exclusive 10 10 hour run
with ea play on game pass right so there
is something of a of a
of a partnership there a little bit
right and and like addict said you just
want people you want to draw people to
the xbox ecosystem above all right so
do you think dropping this affects
battlefield in any way shape or form
especially because king loved it right
but there's plenty of people saying that
it's it's a buggy mess
um i they got bad xboxes oh my god
so
let's let's say let's say the general
thinking is it's a buggy mess it's not
where it should be or could be
does this does dropping a halo tomorrow
affect that game
because i think they're not they're not
they're not your competition per se
they're your partners right yes yeah
your partner i think it would make it
would make more sense if they dropped
before battlefield
but it is weird that you would choose
after battlefield because there is a
chance that it came out and it's not
buggy right and it's a huge success
so not coming out before
hurts you
then coming out after
but you know
i don't think they unless you know
obviously these people know internally
what's going on with these third-party
developers you know i'm not saying that
they intentionally trying to you know
let's push up let's push up uh let's
push our battle i mean
halo because we know battlefield about
to drop like i don't think nothing like
that's going out but you know they're
probably like look there's a lot of
multiplayer stuff going out
uh let's let's push up halo because we
do want it to have it shine and it's
like i said and then we hit him with
that one two punch that one punch that
left hook that's that's the multiplayer
and then two weeks later you're in the
news for almost an entire month between
fours and between halo two weeks later
they're not now now they're not talking
about call of duty play because it's
calmed down but now they're gonna be
talking about halo all that week yeah
the the campaign
it's it's that after the campaign you
dropped that first knowledge of the next
expansion for forza i say you teach uh
ea a lesson
you teach ea a lesson you want to hedge
your bet you want to play games you
already see what call of duty's doing
over there with these dudes the
exclusive deals and you over here giving
us some little 10-hour trial yeah sure
you got the king to play 10 hours but he
uninstalled after 10 hours so
what you should have did was you should
have put that game inside game pass to
really engage with your public but you
didn't do that so you put one foot in
one foot out when you put one foot in in
a relationship and one foot out the
relationship next out is the door so
teach them a lesson put that halo out
and show them how committed you are to
your platform because they should have
been committed as well so i will be
engaging with halo to an extent that's
incredible if it launches inside gamepad
so
question to you guys um because next
week clearly we're going to be talking
about
uh i i'm pretty sure we'll be talking
about the video game awards right next
week or do you want to do that the week
after no i'm talking about iop because
the nominations are coming out yeah once
the nominations come out we probably do
yeah they come out tuesday so
but we may have something special
popping next yeah uh so you know we're
not going to go too much into it yeah
but so
my question is whenever we do do the
video game awards things like what what
do you think
in terms of
all this good publicity that halo's got
all this good publicity that the
multiplayer's got you have
uh miranda and ryan that was definitely
skeptical of the campaign but they came
out very satisfied yes
do you think that this might be the
first 90 plus halo in years
i'm not ready to go there just yet
i just let's let's let's worry about
positive vibes
listen we know the multiplayer for the
most part we feel strong
we feel when they don't let us rock out
they let us bait a boy out as king you
know he could keep laughing why oh why
is the fraud alert on me what do i do
what is that alert you know because he's
he's in the same boat with me he's like
you're not acquiescing you have to get
100 you got to give 100 so i have to say
it's going to be a 95 better credit
because i didn't play it what i'm saying
is what i'm going to say oh lord where
where are we at with this as far as
they've been showing you for since since
what what flight simulator yeah yeah
we've been about this life
like it's been crazy that these games is
raiding at they chart and hit how many
times does beyonce have to drive all
right but
way home
90 plus
plus that's the horizon drop back that's
horizon this is pretty good
what the horizon dropped because i think
there is a difference
do you think there's a difference
between horizon and call of duty i mean
uh halo because
horizon is kind of in a genre that it's
dominating there's not really a lot of
competition when you review these games
they don't have a whole lot to go off
absolutely
gran turismo has been in limbo for years
uh need for speed you know they they are
hit and miss forza does nothing but drop
consecutive quality games so i do think
naturally it does get a curve because
that's all you get
halo is a first person shooter
has got call of duty got battlefield got
it got destiny it does got competition
all the beauty is doing the same old
school thing
we can't act like halo won't be held to
a higher standard than forza well and
it's gonna because it's gonna rise to
the occasion you got to stand up all
right
here we go let me go you know what it is
okay let me see so you know what it is
i'm gonna sit there and say yeah it's
gonna be 90 plus i'm gonna say it's
gonna be 90 plus right so when he's on
the line for that 90 plus for what you
don't want him you really don't you know
what worries me about that king is that
oh you talking about these dudes going
there and they're not bombing it but
yeah exactly this is the thing right
for whatever reason right horizon
horizon i have not seen the negative
thing said about horizon like across the
board which is which is rare which is
rare very rare i have not seen a single
it's like everybody wants somebody into
submission that's what happens when it
comes to getting on youtube i can't wait
till this time
i know i know that people that actively
don't want it to succeed
you know it's true
you know how i knew that forza was that
game
when spawn wave someone that mainly
plays on switch came out on twitter and
said all right we need to revisit this
game of the year for the talk
it's just like yeah it is different in a
way that i know people are going to want
to nitpick everything about halo
i wanted to be there
and they gonna have to bend the knee and
they're going to be doing what
everybody's been doing since flight
simulator hit first this is the
narrative flight shipment in the real
game
you know what i noticed
they're going to be narratives
same man
we watch craig
he said they put boo-boo on the screen
this is the same man right so my thing
is all i'm saying is multiplayer no
doubt but the the the campaign you got
something they showed the campaign and i
heard a lot of people
don't listen to you
your old feel is back my chest is
wiggling it's all filled back yeah so
now all of us know we're going to go 90
plus we're not doing right now
you know you know why i'm going to say
that i'm about to put a poll in the chat
about the meta credit is multiplayer
campaign separate rated
no it's a complete package so one could
one could really dethrone the other the
other one
okay so but but but look at this part
right uh-huh
people are gonna say oh when that god of
war come out it's gonna be 90 plus right
right
you can say that with no doubt because
there's a track record you know you can
record this trash i don't like the game
like that so the track record is a 76
for me
you want to be king
oh my god right off the rip you can't
make it
so there we go he can't eat no
i'm not even gonna do that but again
like i said these dudes can look at
games that aren't even out and say
look you in your faces yes i mean that's
gonna be a nice rush and i'm gonna look
them in the face too because i did not
see craig and it's a 90-plus all right
because the biggest thing that they were
scared of before was craig face this
there's a difference between optimism
and hubris
and we're flirting
i got a poll in the chat for people
that's not looking in the chat you know
vote where you think the halo
metacritic's going to uh all i'm saying
is they got a lot to prove on the
campaign side and it's positive signs
already i like that let's get the full
game but it's a 90 plus pauses
full game out before we do these these
boisterous
proclamations
a lot of the games like it's just like
look like
i'm just curious off going off what we
know now because i don't think we're
going to get a lot more information
i don't know anything they ign is out
here playing i don't know nothing i'm
not playing nothing so as far as i'm
concerned i'm just happy that they came
they came in
scared to death they came in off a halo
5 like oh god
right that's a great start i
if somebody walking to the joint i was i
had trepidations
and then i walked out i'm a believer you
got converted by walking in the room
what the hell is what went on in that
and you're fearless in that regard i
always give you that you're fearless and
i know what you're saying i just need i
unlike my family i was burned by halo
5's campaign i didn't like it i felt it
was falsely marketed it did not give me
weight
too much
bro i'm like i was not there and then
bro you know when they had me it was
definitely for y'all because when they
had me is we did like a stage and then
we walked into a room and an achievement
pop and it said the next stage is
complete i was like what is going on
that that
then the no fleshing out of the the
teams and and then it was like oh we're
gonna fight and dennis you know what man
we good
smart lock master g we good let's forget
about all that marketing and all that we
good let's just team up and rock out
like no we gonna do a proper narrative
and we're going to give halo the respect
it it deserves and i know so far i think
i think it's going to be a high
i think it's going to be a high 80s game
like 86 87 88 around there
i mean you you're very confident about
that when i brought that ben the knee
you kind of kind of revoke it on that
but
how many knees do you want to lose to me
how many times do you want me to be
really the prophet
this is one of those times
look this is one of those times king i
will ha i will gladly hand you my knee
if i'm wrong i will do you you know what
it is okay i get it might give you some
of the thigh my aunt
[Laughter]
does it does it even have to be 90 like
we're all over here talking about i
agree
like
psychonauts 2 is one of my game of the
year contenders that's an 88 or
something right like
no it's a 91. it's an ideal one pc right
mm-hmm
like these dudes review bombers they're
weirdos like that and i feel like
they're gonna do that to this game here
so you think i'm gonna put my needs onto
something that can't be uh uh
technically really controlled
where you can literally have a dude love
the game play the game end the game then
go in there and say i hate it so you're
not going to win okay no no but i'm
control that narrative but look we beat
this to death um let's go let's go
we'll see what happens tomorrow it'll
it'll be lit so i'm super chatting we
are streaming that correct yes you
you're streaming thank you i'm showing
it no you get what i'm saying i know i
don't [ __ ] mess with you all right
let me
roll this in a little bit okay it's all
good it's so good while you do that i
got some merch i could read while you're
doing that yeah read the merch out um
yeah more stuff coming in wow yeah
they doing this merch hall but yeah
necromancer's a z say yeah we got him um
bizarre rabbit he said he put
a bizarre rabbit he got the premium
pullover hoodie with the all natty
my number one favorite podcast thank you
lord awesome put the crest up much love
much love and i believe yeah that was
the last one right there we got that in
and wearing that all natty yeah will
allow you to unlock the fable tool
keep in mind
but regardless what he's saying keep in
mind that uh when you guys get these
this merchandise man tag the iop and
post that on twitter we always like see
we like seeing people rap especially
these all natty stuff you know i i want
to see people wearing kings on on their
chests remember what i talked about with
fable
like keep in mind not only are you
wearing this man in your chest he gonna
be like this oh
hey yo and as you as you listen and as
you walk past i say weird in the gym
right and when you went up again and
then she's on the spot machine she said
can you spot me
yeah
that's what i want to see i want to see
everybody doing the all natty with the
shirt
don't don't be doing these things have
fun with it
you know you know what we'll do
you know every now and then we'll go
over so do hashtag iop on twitter and
we'll go over
all of those sometimes
yo slow-mo said this is not going to
increase it
i'm buying mine right now
so i just got a question for you man i
got are you sure
uh so first of all again last
broadcaster get at me on twitter let me
get that read the dm so i'm gonna give
you this code
um
afterwards we have don otaku two dollars
super chat yo king are you getting that
gucci xbox yeah
no
okay so that thing is ten thousand
dollars yeah and i will advise against
anyone flirously throwing money away in
that manner do not do that come on man
please cut that out fair enough enough
gerald mack two dollars super chat
salute to lord king david battlefield
2042 hitting hard okay so he's like yeah
crazy
[Music]
then we have uh rrd two dollar super
chat king did the ten hours start when
you hit when you hit download
nah nah so as soon as you engage and you
got into the world
that you know i'm
y'all see like i really want to talk
about it but y'all see no doubt no doubt
then we got aaron j f 94 two dollars
we'll
i love that let's go
and we got christian r dollar super chat
i'm all in with forza right now i'm not
ready for haters
yeah some people do feel that yeah king
making some good points with that i'm
ready for halo
you can do that
there's people that would never play
forza who was like ready for yes it's
gonna be interesting
man i'm gonna tell you guys right now
if that drops tomorrow i'm gonna be
streaming that number
listen says the man that had forza a
week before that did the review
that's cool you could you know first off
you could you could have got that that
early access well but you did no i could
not so my wife so you know like that so
you know
that's fine you can go sit in your
little corner and play fours and then
let the rest of us play halo i'm done
one second then we have
romelo five dollar super chat why
haven't 343 and greenberg debunked this
why aren't sites like ign and even some
big xbox influencers coming out and
getting those clicks
or something
they don't know what they're doing right
now they kind of they don't know what
they want to let forza breathe
it could be downtown
it could be a last night it could be a
last minute audible because that yeah
this is interesting okay
then we have flame five dollars let's be
real
for fourth horizon five is doing well
because it launched with no caveats it
has co-op forge and the battle royale
let halo cook wow
halo cup go russian throw you in the
bushes sir
you can't throw our scrap in above the
bush i'ma throw you straight in the
bushes says stop playing with that
slander i don't care about your forge i
don't care about your co-op and i don't
care about your multiplayer give me my
story and jump out the way you could not
throw the lords and gave it that that
school because i can be in here
then we got scrub nurse member for 18
shout out to scrub nurse it's been a
while since we've seen him yeah
fantastic shout out to the lords and the
chat hit that like button subscribe and
play as much as possible before the next
game jumps on the scene hashtag the
struggle yes these are very much first
world struggles that we're having right
now
that we have splendiferous two dollars
super chat
nothing messing with halo bro them games
got four minutes saying they're done
you the exact reason why it's not coming
out
savage
then we got pixel bit g
two dollar super chat halo best fps
since doom 90 plus hate won't stop it
lessons that's right stand by me stand
by me in the muffin mine
that was hilarious
then we got donald taco five dollars in
chat halo infinite will be the fourth
ten from ign for xbox game studios this
year 90 plus on metacritic 100
okay okay that's right king got his
soldiers out he ran that's right ride
with me
the wise old gamer five dollars here we
go the ad campaign for halo is crazy
went to pick up a pack of condoms last
night
on the back of the box was cheap and a
quote finish this fight
that was bars he's so out of pocket
filthy wise old gamer
so nervous
nervous when he's super chat
i love i love the filthy old man i love
it i love it
he's the kind of person i'd like to go
to family reunions he's like okay you
got to watch what you say around there
yeah
that was good though that was good still
welcome no filter
someone makes the sake wrong
[Music]
master chief is all daddy i'm done
[Laughter]
then we got victor alestine five dollars
morning lords do you think the rock and
bill will be there tomorrow just like at
the beginning you know that would be
something crazy that would be cool
back to the s's that would be crazy got
bigger and the other one got smaller
yeah
and we have splendiferous once again two
dollars a champ addict out here giving
away cakes not a good look what are you
thinking
about the chicken
oh to cheat me
he's the one that that was suggesting
the cheeks is
[Music]
a counterpoint to the discussion of
forza vs halo multiplayer cod and
battlefield already out for thanksgiving
does xbox want the halo multiplayer out
to get those things
you know yeah you think about after you
finish eating on thursday you know like
what am i going to do watch some
football
real quick i never do this but 700 of
y'all in the chat we having a lot of
good fun
muffin money please hit the like button
really appreciate it share this out to a
friend of a friend let them know about
the muffin mine man let them know about
this good talk we have it man 700 listen
i tell y'all we get to 15 000
subscribers going to be a concert yeah
yeah y'all getting a console y'all y'all
listen we always give back like king
said it always goes back to y'all y'all
hit the like i do that stuff we put it
right back to your cousin right now fast
and if you got a twin brother he should
be supporting like the muffins yeah
[Laughter]
a shill five dollar super chat king it
now makes sense why all the kids look
like you in fable too
i thought it was some sort of flaw in
the code turns out you were crystal dean
you know what's crazy i've always
thought like king has like the same body
type it looks a lot similar to like
thunder and fable he's like
yeah could you imagine no god named
thunder come on man
oh he'd really be doing that like you
got you like when you get a chance king
google thunder from fabled oh i'm doing
it now
we got the dutch rudder five dollar
shipping chat i'm so excited for
tomorrow i am insert inappropriate
metaphor congrats to the lord who made
cancer their witch salim yes hello
hello no doubt
all right that we have flame two dollars
of japanese let's go king throw him up
just kidding i'll lose
yeah you will
absolute
then we have matt titchbomb
vaughn
right because i think he'd be getting at
us
yeah i think i got it right there he is
how you know that character what is
wrong with you guys
i'll show the realm of my phone he looks
just like him he's out of control
it's out of control it's literally out
of control
you found it
no i i'm going to uh put it on my phone
just keep reading the super bowl all
right there we go uh so matt titch bomb
five pound super chat saw some rumors
already saying that the planned release
for tomorrow has been pushed back yeah
we talked about it we talked about it
could be audible last minute we'll see
could be then we have to breathe apollo
dingo five dollars
why the saw value persona games so much
they don't sell nearly as well see
thanks
i don't care but i never played a prison
on the game i don't care
like yeah hey they was like you don't
know what he talked about i thought of
comments i was like get them
the question is the question is why does
sony value them so much that they have
to try to they take them right
they block xbox from getting them that's
for sure what's this
he's showing you the guy that looked
like me
straight up hands yeah highly ridiculous
yeah that's ridiculous shout out what's
funny is that that that's your rival's
brother and if you kill your rival he
pulls up on you at the end of the game
and you have to fight him
you have to put it on the other side
because on the logos and people
purchasing merch is popping up right
there so you have to put it on the other
side of the screen yeah for that
and i got to i gotta give a shout out to
apollo for talking about last week's
topics in today's
chat cause i'm like he's saying it like
i'm talking about it real strong right
now
yeah put on go go live please yeah yeah
you know enjoy them there you go
yeah now you can see it
all good there he is yeah they laughing
they say yep that's king
and king he was a beast
he was extremely powerful in that game
oh god
then we have uh let's put the crest in
the chat for d skills town shout out to
these girls town
put the crust in the chat and use me all
right my boy i put it in my fault y'all
add it one more time i'm sorry one more
time put it up because i forgot i had
the logo going my bad is killing me all
right now y'all gonna get to see
this character he can't get it gary
who's blocking it yeah now y'all can see
it
i'm gonna do it on the other side i
ain't doing it again
and i'm gonna give you guys a middle
shot
it's like i said the only way you can
fight him is if you kill your rival got
you all right let's go yeah yeah the the
black knight said put it in the center
pause pause pause
[Music]
let's really pause out here
[Laughter]
let's keep it moving y'all we are super
loud all right so raiden blade five five
super chat hello lords i believe the
halo forge is coming with uh with vr and
br forge editor
then it will be catering to everyone
gamers and streamers like dr d what the
hell doctor
perspective
2042 is just what the doctor ordered
plus forza is the goat let halo cook
more and as always hey king boo-boo
uh what else we got hold on a second
that's all
that's it all right let's go and then oh
there was a merch
wow
somebody shout out to tony b
got the premium all natty tank top
you know getting my all natty
in life yeah we need to see all of this
on twitter
you gotta go over them see yo need you
spot me
[Laughter]
i can't this is crazy movement right
there get a special
get get a special all-natty uh
uh gym shirt made that just says spot me
on it
but um yeah so let's get into it all
right so some room is going on right now
xbox exclusives looks like they're
leaking
oh shout out to uh jazz corden uh
windows yeah they're not leaking jess
just turned on the faucet
shout out to jeff grove as well so well
let's start with jazz um receive uh
details on compulsions first outing is
part of xbox game studios currently
codename midnight the upcoming title is
supposed to be a third person action
game setting a dark and fantastical
world some of the games early concept uh
artwork was leaked so it has a female
protagonist african-american sister i
believe and um yeah so it looks like the
game they said alongside uh warped
harpy-like humanoids that appeared to
descend through various iterations of
mutations midnight is described as a
coming-of-age tale drawing upon
inspiration from america's deep south
the game features magic and large
fantastical beasts with strong southern
gothic vibe game is wholly a single
player experience described with a
strong story and then the second game is
obsidian good old boys obsidian
pentamete
which was revealed by jeff grubb this is
the indie style game by led by jeff
sawyer and i believe he was also part of
the um one of the best fallouts as far
as vegas and pillar of eternity and uh
yeah it's pretty much again the name
pentamite which refers to an underlying
image in a painting and it's supposed to
be the game's primer supposed to be an
investigator in 16th century europe
uncovering the truth behind a grisly
murder also hearing some possible
narrative branching designs maybe i'll
discover losing him so we see that and
the one
for me i'll be biased
uh again shout out to jeff grubb you
know he's out there
one versus 100 may soon make a comeback
the company's all space vr team is
working on a project with full support
from the xbox games division so for
those who don't know one verse 100 was a
big interaction you know why i think
that 100 is coming back
it was that
that questionnaire question thing they
did for e for e3 that
that that completely fell apart i feel
like when they did that they're like we
could bring one versus hundred back in
this same way wow it would be it would
be something so look three big games i i
sent some streams if that ever comes
back oh yeah bro
so let's get the buffalo in here man
what are we thinking you know obsidians
compulsions new game one versus 100
these rumors seem strong so what are we
thinking man about these three yeah we
uh we talked about this on project x
talk this week but i
i'm excited about if all this comes true
i think it really bolds well i've never
been compulsions biggest fan um their
games don't they haven't hit for me in
the past i like the concept artwork that
we see for the like the harpy wings and
the 16th century like our
the deep south about the 16th century i
don't know much about the deep south so
like if we can if we can integrate those
elements i think we can have a really
interesting game but i'm all about like
fantasy worlds that really appeals to me
so i give them the time because they
really need like a game to hit they
haven't had a big success for me
for
uh pentamit yes this is this is the game
that i think is the most exciting for me
personally being being the rpg guy
i haven't gotten around to disco elysium
yet me too sir yeah yeah i've been
hearing you talk about it
the last couple weeks my co-host tom
over there he put like 30 hours into it
told me i gotta play it so i i'm waiting
for game pass if i'm being honest like
listen i tried to wait for game pass too
it's probably going to come but yeah
yeah they showed it there's always
yeah yeah so uh if we can't like uh xbox
getting their own disco elysium i think
that would be awesome you know that
would go day one in game pass really
give people that
xbox is going all in on rpgs every every
type of rpgs we're getting turn based
rpgs we've got crpg an action rpg it's
they're firing on all cylinders there we
could say that with confidence correct
yeah yeah and one versus 100 that's
gonna be amazing that is going to be
oh my god tom on my pocket on project
actually he did not know what this game
was and i was like bro you had no idea
like one versus 100
there was a real life game show called
number 100 that is exactly the same
premise you get one person you gotta
face the mob of 100 people but this was
a virtual space you get to log in you
get to win prizes the mob can win prizes
if you take down the one person like
they were giving away games microsoft
points
you can you can rack up get free games
from from xbox like
who would not love this who would not
love logging in set time every week
being like me and the homies are going
to go try to destroy someone or maybe
you're the lucky one
you're the lucky one that gets to be
like i'm going to school you all with
this trivia knowledge and then i'm going
to walk away with 50 000 xbox points and
go spending spree yeah i'm with you
brother i'm with you [ __ ] away with an
all nighter t-shirt
a lot of people don't realize how much
of a movement like like what the mom was
saying it was man i'm with you on that
so yeah you're excited looks like penta
pen to mint is your number one and then
oh yeah okay out of three
lord addict man with these three games
obsidian compulsion
project midnight project pentameter one
verse 100. what's your thought on all
three of these
i don't really like it doesn't seem like
the obsidian ones for me uh i'll
probably you know stick more towards the
outer worlds too and about
but um you know the the one versus 100 i
really like
that that's coming back because i played
a little bit of one versus 100 but i
didn't play like a whole lot i played a
couple weeks but i remember like that
was a big thing for you know i probably
played it for like six months almost
weekly but like after that i didn't
really touch it ever again but it is
like one of those fun things because
you know they
they used to like make it theme too like
halo week or something like that where
they would ask you
and i hope that the biggest thing is i
want the interface to be smooth and
clean yes that like kind of like how
they did it with that
that uh that that thing that we was
doing where it's like you know i don't
want it to be gimmicky i want it to be
look clean
i i wanted to have a good visual
appearance doing it um
make it a free to play like
make it to where like you know you you
can uh
you get coins in the in game just by
participating where you can like buy
clothing for your avatar in there like
the avatar customization that really
took avatars to the next level because
yeah continue i agree with you on that
yeah and you know i think you know i
think microsoft because they have these
zero servers they need to go above and
beyond like have a whole hub of games
that do that like i feel like they need
to bring back
there's a couple games that have always
felt like they're missing their their
target like fusion frenzy like i wasn't
the biggest fan of it but i think that
you know
there isn't a lot of games like mario
party out there and i think it you know
it couldn't cost a whole whole lot of
money to make another fusion frenzy and
i feel like especially something like
game pass put that in
fusion frenzy and game pass like you
know i know something like the squid
games is really popular like imagine if
you if you got with them and was
permission to make a squid games that
was like
like 500 people just like one versus 100
to where you had to press a button had
all the squid game stuff like i met like
you would be the social network like the
place where you wanted you want to buy
that console just to play those games
and they're in the majority all of them
are free or maybe in game pass yeah
that's that
tremendous potential completely agree
solve out of the three project midnight
project pentiment and one versus 100
which of these three potential rumors
what do you feel about all three nah man
they're all exciting to be honest that
one where one person's 100 was was a
movement like it was one of those things
we're like really we can do this we can
log and it works like it's one of those
things when you're like all right let's
see how it works right this is does it
all chop up does nobody is no one able
to connect like and it just worked from
day one i remember like i got i got
close to like the last ring or the first
time that i played i was like oh man all
right so next week let's do it and for
whatever reason
it just you could almost tell
when things started to shift within
microsoft a little bit
because it they killed it for no reason
very abrupt it's not like it was it was
unpopular it was it was this thing that
was so forward-thinking and then for
whatever reason just killed it and i
would have thought that you know with
all this talk about especially when you
started talking about game pass and
engagement and all that stuff i'm like
this is the definition of engagement
this is the definition of getting people
in
to play something in the
in the meta version
right
so
um i'm if i hope this is true
if it does i want to see what it becomes
because it never got a chance to evolve
into what it could have been before
you know what we got to do so like man
you guys got to got a hashtag at the
mall when that game comes out we need
king to be the first one up for 100.
my trivia knowledge is crap
but you can go with the ghost
you can trust them all destroy me yeah
yeah i can trust them
you know it would be cool too
if they open up like a private version
or you know it's like like open it and
you no no no i i'm gonna go deeper into
this where like stuff like like
communities like us could set one up
with our own questions in reason don't
let them be answering like crazy stuff
like like imagine if we did like where
did crystal d come from
imagine imagine if we did if they will
allow like you to host your own lobby
and
[Music]
and then the community at large picks
one to spotlight for the week
crazy that'd be crazy
so that i'm excited for that second
because when you uh i played disco
elysium when it came out on pc right
before it came to console that game
fifth time you purchased it right
hush
we'll
that game that that game is very special
because it's like cox said it's not it's
not combat heavy it is about you seeing
the unraveling of this individual and
the different ways you could take it
because the thing is the game is all
about the personalities that are inside
his head yes
and
they are so
they are either so on board to what he's
doing or so against what he's doing
it is
in a lot of ways the most special game
i've played in terms of an rpg and what
rpgs do for me now
they elevated that when they added voice
to it oh
because the game was great before
when they added the the level of voice
they added to it is great so to think
that pentamen is in that line and have
an xbox version of those with the
geniuses that obsidian behind it when it
comes to when it comes to narrative in
in in rpgs
and rpgs obsidian obsidian is kind of
second to none they're very they're very
very good so i'm excited about that
now the last one midnight let's go when
i saw what it was and they talked about
the deep south i saw the protagonist i
saw this the harpies that kind of looked
like something out of gotcha man
it looked great now
i'm excited for it the thing that kind
of oh
it's just the fact that when i looked at
it immediately it looked like force
spoken to me
oh
okay and i was like damn i don't want to
see those damn comparisons and i know
for spoken is next year and this is
probably out so right that's probably it
doesn't matter but
it was just one of those things when i
saw the protagonist i kind of saw the
conceit of the story
or just kind of the conceit of the world
i was like damn it kind of looks like
for spoken i just hope that those
comparisons don't matter in the long run
because what i think they're doing over
there
the conceptual stuff yeah so um
what what they're talking about like a
story in the deep south yo with a
female protagonist of color like and all
this other weird stuff going on in the
back like compulsion
i thought i knew you guys were going to
come up with something kind of special
and off the rails you could tell story
wise when it came to we happy few it was
there yeah
this feels like they're going to get
that along with the action game play
i think you're getting you just won cog
like it really feels like that's what it
is
i'm excited i'm excited i'm excited for
them because they're they're a small
they're a small team
and obviously i don't think this game
gonna be like a 35 hour experience
whatever but
it does feel like it's going to be
something special so i'm excited for all
of that everything that they talked
about that leaked shout out to jess
i i'm excited for so much
your three these three games project
midnight compulsion project pentamete
obsidian and one versus 100 thoughts on
all three sir
um i think you leaked this list
[Laughter]
it is for him right
every game there
screams i did it yeah
they said i'm smoking them into
existence
[Music]
once i knew the dead giveaway for you
was one versus 100 yo
i said come on man
you said that the other day like no this
is impossible so i said so at this
at this point man it's jazz and call i'm
just saying we never see jackson cog in
the same room
i am not an insider we
know who deep throw this pulse
like yeah you know you know
watergate i start playing i know you've
got listen learn your history
yeah be doing that voice continue
know because that's how they sound like
to me on twitter
you know so
i just look at the list i'm like this
abs because it's
i'm not gonna say there's nothing for me
i know it's like i know it's that these
are like i don't know like it's really
your list like this is like if you had
to write and you did this the other day
like literally everything that's there
if y'all go back and watch the other
show
that one versus 100 is a dead giveaway
is this dude okay
okay if that's a dead giveaway you don't
you don't get the title and the name
right like you can say a game show type
game
no it's one versus 100 and he said yeah
we coming back with that what
no so do i believe it i don't really
think so but
if it happens
i believe
game pass will take one versus one
hundred actual to us
don't make that free to play
make that game live only in game pass
right and make that fomo happen that
the the level of conversation about that
game
could you imagine what engagement
numbers would look like they would have
to do multiple days out of the week
because if they have millions of of
gamers that's inside game pass then you
have to have millions of those game
shows technically because
you know it can't be on one specific day
it will have to be multiple and then the
streaming aspect of it the eyes alone on
on that game will definitely blow up um
the the single player uh
you know um deep south game
i want to see more yeah fair i really
want to see more and the disco lazium
type stuff i i got to play it again all
right i really i'm i'm hoping to come to
game pass
no this is coming to game pass yeah it
is coming out with us because we already
saw in the third the third party
showcase
and they did that and every game that
has been shown yeah probably third party
showcases
they just need sovereign to buy it two
more times
um
yeah like this case
this is like
this is like literally everything i
could have personally wanted you know as
far as let's start with um compulsion
project midnight you know we had um the
amazing you know nalia on from community
manager from compulsion games you know
she debuted that it would be a third
person
game shout out to slo-mo for asking the
question i believe he was on he asked
that question on the show
um you know to me i'm not gonna get like
first of all this is hashtag just one
let's just get it out the way this is a
hashtag just one game um they're heavy
story narrative story beat new ip right
now i know shout out to my brother
fonzerelli i don't know if he's in the
chat but i don't mean going back and
forth a little bit behind the scenes as
far as triple a budget and whether or
not that qualifies but this my counter
today and i understand it's concerned
because he wants
fonz wants to like um
last of us level
triple a super production value right
and my thing is
i don't know that right what's what this
is the chances are maybe it's not maybe
it's double it right i don't know but i
will say this
that i'm not gonna
kind of drag it over to kohl's yet
because i think of when
hellblade one first came out
and that was kind of like a mid to small
size team by ninja theory at the time
right and they punched above their
weight right and make something that is
now critically acclaimed one of these
most amazing unique experiences going so
my thing is i want to afford compulsion
that opportunity to see what they do
under microsoft's banner second phil did
say
the studio everyone is sleeping on is
compulsion he did they did allude that
the game that they were most excited for
is most likely this game right so and
i'm with king
this deep south
female african-american protagonist in
that time period they got the potential
to really go there and be edgy on some
things i don't know where they're going
with the story if it's you know whatever
but at the end i just already like the
premise and one thing addict you you
could attribute with as you're a huge we
happy few guy
the potential of we have people who
sleep potentially we happy few was
immense it's just that this studio had
been through so many trials this studio
almost closed down like two separate
times prior to microsoft they're lucky
to be around right so to see them with
this with a budget
and a vision i'm super excited for them
super excited pentamete you already know
that's gonna speak to my soul detective
anything resembling disco elysium i'm in
plus it's obsidian sawyer and my only
issue with disco is i feel
like it's really kind of like a pc game
the way you move around and i feel the
control could be a little bit better so
if they do a better production value of
a disco elysium and it's exclusive i'm
in 14300 man come on man like this this
is man
bro
the potential it is i'm just thinking
about the avatars it's interesting that
the vr team is working with it is
interesting did you use a vpn
um i didn't know when you slid when when
you sleep
[Music]
when it comes to the the compulsion game
like
i get where
where fonz is coming from but to me like
we don't need every game looking like
last of us and
his credit i'm listen i'm i know where
you're going i don't know where he's
going to his credit he wants to see
money on the screen like he want that
triple m
just because it doesn't look like last
of us doesn't mean there's not money on
the screen look at borderlands that's
money on the screen
and it doesn't look like last year so
i will say this though
um and i've talked about this in the
past
i don't want if i if that game pentiment
is
the same sort of type of premise and
gameplay that you'd get from a disco
elysium
if you make it either a third-person
game or a third-person game that's not
in the that is not kind of isometrically
sort of played like this collision is
right
i i think you get more eyes on it it's
just the reality of it oh for sure
if pentamen turns out to be a great
isometric rpg whatever it's going to be
great and it's going to have it's the
people who love it but it's definitely
going to limit the amount of people that
are interested in it just just by
looking at it oh for sure for sure for
sure i mean but this is where i caught
them in my king bag where it's like in
attic bag which is like
they've got
so much diversity of titles in the
ecosystem right now
and i know fans don't like to hear this
part but it's like bro like
we're not going to act like hellblade2
ain't got that production value that
yeah
it's just that it doesn't fall into my
little cell phone with the new ip but
that hits
that boom bastard like when that joint
was shown and they in iceland or
wherever they at and they do it like bro
they're throwing money at that game and
that's gonna appreciate that the crazy
part is
like i know people forget this but gears
is a third-person action adventure too
so it's like it's not like that they're
like is that you know
missing right it's just yeah that's what
i'm saying like look just because new ip
right
just because compulsion first off i
don't understand why anyone's logic was
thinking compulsion was going to have
that realistic graphic type artwork
because they've never done that in
contrast okay we happy few their artwork
has always been more of the bioshock
than anything else
and to me if if you look if you thought
that you were gonna get like an
uncharted type of graphical experience
from them right you're not paying
attention right to me it's like
f dr country but what he may be looking
for is
what coalitions next one
possibly could be with unreal
engine before they do a gears game we
don't know if they're gonna do a third
person kind of thing but
i agree i know where you're going with
that i know you go based on the history
of the studio i know what you're
continuing
like
compulsion
i see them more of a spiritual successor
to bio uh not uh to um the people who
made bioshock i can't remember their
their name right um
and i don't think there's nothing wrong
with that like you know i think that
you're going to get a fantastic
you know story from them because
regardless sure was we happy few what it
should have been no right but there's a
lot of factors that went into what made
we happy few there was shifts in
changing mid development there was shift
and changing when uh uh gearbox gave
them money as a publisher and then they
you know microsoft had to give them
money to fit it to finish that that home
stretch like you know i i understand
that the concept of we happy few a lot
of things that missed but if you play
the expansions you see that that's a
very narrative joking
driven
exp expansions and
i see you're gonna get
that similar type of artwork probably
more of a bioshock type of artwork uh
it's looking like it's gonna be you know
some time like what the 80s or 70s yeah
and you're going to get like a darker
tone
what episode probably i mean they're
talking about deep south i mean they
didn't say whether it seems like it's a
modern tale or something you know way
back in the past it might just be just
kind of its own thing where it's like
some supposed whatever weird alternate
future or something like that right yeah
i feel like you're gonna you're gonna
get that artwork type of like bioware
you're gonna get a very
driven uh
fir you're gonna get a very driven
third-person
action-adventure narrative story-focused
game with you know not necessarily
realistic graphics but it's like
psychonauts right
not a realistic graphic thing game looks
gorgeous because of the way it was done
i feel but i even want to be careful
with seeing not realistic graphics yet
because we just see concept art and
that's another thing i can almost i can
almost guarantee you 100 it's it's going
to be
it's not going to be that type of see
the engine move that's what i'm saying
because when the engine moving if it hit
it look like it's doing something that's
well that's what i'm saying like
depending on how the animations are done
and how the game generally is made like
it's like psychonauts psychonauts is a
very was a you know didn't have a huge
budget but because of the way they
designed the world and they did the
artwork that's a very visually appealing
game but let me get buffalo real quick
on midnight because i know we focus on
that but like
do we think because we are under the
understanding that this is microsoft
this is compulsion game under the
microsoft bank yes
so that's why again correct me if i'm
wrong like i'm still a little bit more
excited i don't want to just limit like
it automatically has to be this smaller
kind of indie kind of thing well i
didn't say smaller not you i'm not you
i'm not in general now i'm interested
because some people i noticed we're
saying that but does that part excite
you or do you look at the concept all
right my friend lina say you know what
no i'm gonna keep my expectation maybe
in a double a indie space
no yeah i think that does excite me
oh sorry
did you want to i was just going to say
i do think it's it will probably be
in the between double a to triple a like
i think it's about probably a 50 50
where it lands like i don't think it's
going to be because there's multiple
levels of everything of a single double
a triple a i don't think if it is a
double eight it's going to be in like
the mid like the middle the the
beginning of a double double-a
experience i think you'll get something
like maybe a ninja theory production
value where it's a very good-looking
game i think that's what you'll get like
as far as triple-a like i don't know if
it will get that far into that type of a
budget but
all we could see off of what we know now
we don't know
if we can evaluate where it is in that
standard we only know concept art we
don't know exactly what's going on in
terms of if it's a double a triple a or
a single a like i hate that term in
general double a triple a single a but
people seem to like using that but right
now we only know a concept art and i
don't think that's enough information to
determine where it sits at in those
functions
yeah no i was i was going to echo
similar sentiments and saying like you
if we look at compulsions past games
they haven't really been those those
titles it's not a triple a like like the
last of us that people are expecting i
don't think microsoft hands them the
they're going to hand them a bigger
budget for sure they're going to be like
make the game you want to make i don't
think they're going to hand them you
know 250 million
you're going to make our flagship triple
a
no no i mean just looking at their past
kids they're like you haven't earned it
yet well if you if you we're gonna give
you some money if you if this game hits
and everyone loves it going in game pass
obviously
we'll see what happens there and then
next game maybe you get a little a
little budget increase so you keep
making
what you want to make but i think they
got to earn it first and compulsion the
only thing going for them i think is
phil being like i'm super excited for
their game so obviously he's he believes
in it and he's gonna back it with some
with some cash yeah listen man shout out
to one bad mother that's my homie he
said xbox i think compulsions games will
surprise they've hired people that
insinuate that isn't a little niche game
and that's what i heard too so i'm not
i'm not willing let me get this ball i'm
not willing to
automatically say it's going to be this
smaller
you know niche kind of experience i i
still think there's a there's a lot of
potential here and my my thing is this
let's not get caught up off of concept
art that's what i'm saying let's see an
engine let's see it in motion and once
we see that then we can be out of bank
determination but right now all this is
is premise what what the type of game is
going to be and all for all accounts it
does fall under just hashtag just one
new ip and i love female protagonists
and i'm about it so let's see what
happens first before we do that i do
want to see one more thing before we
move on like at the end of the day
uh
even if this is a
you know a high production double a
title
this their what they were doing
and what they're doing now is in a
completely different tax bracket yeah
like they were i was separate studios
like that's what like they they were
probably doing double a
uh
double a work with a fraction of the
money they have now factually so even if
they are doing a double a project we're
we're talking that they got a new studio
they got new they got new uh technology
they got new uh i've been
would see that they've been hiring like
this isn't the same compulsion
where you're and they're not to mention
that they don't have that that that
what's work for the the constant worry
about where the money's gonna come from
they can focus on nothing but the game
and i have half their studios focusing
on different things and we know the
history that's all right yeah i just
think it's when we think about like they
made it clear like they want these
studios to keep making what they what
they want to make right and that doesn't
necessarily mean or we're going to take
the small studio and add 100 people to
it and see what they do right so it
really does feel like when you talk
about like a double a thing i think it's
more double a like in scope the scope is
going to be smaller but the polish is
going to be there it's going to it's
going to have these games i think
looking at all these games that have
recently come out right we start seeing
this sort of pattern where i think
the idea of the level of polish these
games going into game pass are going to
have is kind of crazy um what what they
are going to stick to to me
is the scope like i don't if this game
is a 10 hour game it makes sense to me
it's a 10 hour game same with with
hellblade 2 right hellblade 2 is going
to look amazing i hope they improve the
combat mechanics and stuff because
but i do i think it's going to be a 25
or 30 hour game i don't think that's
what that game is right so
the money's put into
making sure that the product that's
coming out is as polished as possible
but i think scope wise and in terms of
what we expect from these studios in
terms of the narrative things they've
done in the past and what they're good
at i think we're still going to see that
it's just going to be a a level of sheen
on it that yeah
i think the best analogy you can use
when microsoft bought these studios is
they bought these studios that couldn't
be a hundred percent efficient because
they were having to worry about this
worrying about that microsoft bought
these studios and they're doing what
they can to make these studios the best
they can be yeah and i think that you
know you're not going to drastically see
something different from a studio if
they weren't already doing it yeah like
i think there are going to be some like
that have ambitions that they couldn't
do it because of funds that they might
change stuff up right but i think uh
some of these studios they're going to
stick to what they're used to doing but
they're going to do it to to the best
the studio can do it now and not just
half efficiency because they're not
worrying about other things that they
don't have to microsoft worries about
that future's bright excited and 1v300
putting this broken into existence
salute anyway let's move on on super
chats at the end just get into the last
one fly through or super chat yeah
yeah
this is quick um this is king's topic i
can set it up from if he chooses
um yeah
looks like our global sodium is
reporting uh making fewer ps5s due to a
component shortage this was done put out
by the verge and um looks like yeah
global chip shortage man so from my
understanding the company was the same
expected to assemble 16 million units
between april 2021 and march 2022.
um now the figures reportedly down at 15
million sony had publicly predicted it
would sell 14.8 million ps5 consoles
this financial year so while this isn't
a large downward revision it just shows
how tight the supply is likely for the
foreseeable future they go on to talk
about the logistics and supply of
components earlier this month nintendo
cut its switch sales forecast by 1.5
million for the financial year do the
component shortage and this next one i
know to be very true because i was
affected valve steam deck
handheld pc was just delayed by two
months for similar reasons and now won't
ship until february i was one of the sad
recipients of that message
so yeah uh shortages across the board
what is going on forecasting this is
king's
topic
oh you didn't mention xbox though
i guess other people money is not as
long oh my god
[Laughter]
well phil did say
there was uh you know so that s might be
more available you know then
you know
he didn't say we won't have
he just told you to go messing with a
little bit it is it is part of xbox's
narrative not to talk those numbers it
works perfectly for them it works really
really good what happens when you're
ahead of the curve you don't have to get
shot
so apparently
for all those who don't have
this
it's going to get a lot harder for you
to get this
i truly believe sony owns stock and
stockx
[Laughter]
man
it's just it's like it's it's like
tumbling down the steps and they keep
hitting the bump and they can't slow
down the momentum until they hit the
bottom
right and i know it says kenna right
because i was like oh kenneth came out
and i said wow that's a fantastic
looking game
and i thought it was just their joint
but then it's multi-plat now
and then it's a dry season right now
right so you would think
they would lean heavily on ramping up
production and getting consoles to all
those people's hands who didn't get a
chance to get them last year who's still
struggling throughout the year and to
get the news that the they're pulling
back production
this silicon shortage is really getting
out of control yeah it's real all right
because i'm gonna tell you right now for
nintendo to tell you that we're scaling
back nintendo don't scale back nothing
so they're trying to get you as much
switches in your hands with no games as
possible right they don't care right but
then
the steam deck
that's what i said
buddy
because i got the same message that you
got
buddy
this really affects me in this manner so
it came out as a joke that i was gonna
have with the playstation dudes but then
across the board to start hitting every
major chip manufacturer in our chosen
medium
and i'm pretty sure it has affected
everyone that's sitting on this panel at
some form or fashion you know um if you
wanted that switch oled is it a little
harder a little bit harder as the
holidays are coming in and you're trying
to find gifts for your friends and your
family or your you know loved one your
significant other or whatever and you're
looking for these gifts
these gifts will become
shorter and shorter in supply and the
prices will uh
again skyrocket because of the shortage
and the demand for said products
how does it affect everyone on the panel
that's just my question because my steam
deck got pushed back i was really pissed
off i wasn't worried about the other
stuff because i have that but anybody
else yeah muffin about what you think
man global shortage what do you think
about it
uh doesn't doesn't affect me luckily i
got my consoles i ain't getting no
switch oled
and
do nothing with it it's not coming in
hot for you
no
no
i played my switching handheld like five
hours total in three years four years or
whatever okay yeah it sits in its little
dock it's got its home there uh so
the ship shores no matter for me but
for everyone that doesn't currently have
a next-gen console this is gonna this is
gonna suck uh you know we thought it was
it's been rough
last year and luckily i've gotten my
friends and family uh their consoles so
like i got six xboxes and a few
playstations throughout the year for my
friends and family
you know people that can't be like oh i
got the twitter notification wario 64.
let's go um yeah i'm gonna have to go
holla at you
yeah
i got some friends that need help
yeah so so i got them so luckily they're
all set and no one around me needs one
but if you're going like all my kids
really want xbox or playstation for
christmas this year
you better start you better have been
looking first of all for a while now but
if you were like just this weekend you
better get one soon or you're gonna be
waiting until next year like
a while the chip shortage is not going
away anytime soon yeah yeah factual
attic chip shortage where yeah
i don't care
oh you got you got what you got you good
yeah i don't i don't care if uh with
stacy bob and and philip can't get at
gamestop
philip gotta suffer you gotta be able to
i don't i don't care because i mean i i
i sat my happy ass outside of gamestop
for 16 hours to get my stuff so i don't
care if someone can't go on
amazon and get something so
you implied that you put in the work
oh yeah i definitely put in the work i
don't see do you know why stacey bob and
whatever the third name i said can't get
their console because they didn't wait
outside of being stuck
in there they tried to walk in their day
one and get their stuff guess what
stacey you didn't get it they said you
don't come to me
when they sold all the stuff and you
can't get
yo the the steve jackson shut up
daddy you just sitting out there at the
front like no i definitely wasn't i i i
i i was definitely uh it was a struggle
16 hours it was a struggle but you know
i got my stuff and because i struggled
for those 16 hours you won't see me
sitting on twitter named stacy
complaining i didn't get this console i
don't know i don't know
what did stacy do to you man flame who
stacy
look man stacy and bob
they they gonna have to uh
they're gonna have to they're gonna have
to hit that l because they didn't get
those consoles when they could man
sometimes sometimes you gotta make a
choice man you got to go on that ebay
and you got to spin that above
market value
and then look
at this point what's what's your what's
your only choice
i mean you're going to wait another year
there was there was a lull for a minute
right where all right if you were saying
like i'm not buying i'm not paying
you know i'm paying i'm not paying any
more than retail right yeah right there
was a low that you can get it for like
seven right yeah
considering where we're at that's a
reasonable price if you really want that
go get that right what's funny is that's
money time let me tell you how extra let
me tell you extra solvents all right so
so i had my brother was with me and he
was going to sit there regardless and so
i was like yo why don't you you know you
know because if something came through
with yours right you couldn't get yours
like day one or something so i was all
right i was like zachary salt wants to
know if you sit in line crazy like yeah
i was like i was like sorry just send me
the bread for the console so i was like
i'm gonna send you some extra to get you
some food for doing this
so he sent that extra though i you know
i i go to the ups right after the sin in
this i'm like yo you you wanted the two
days or the overnight he's like
overnight
so
it's definitely you know doubling the
price of the stuff that's all they're
playing no games out here ain't playing
those games
i'm playing out there and then when i
couldn't get my my playstation
yeah i i dropped the straight grip like
it was just shout out to the group shout
out to you guys a thousand dollars here
you go thanks shout out to the millions
the millions out because for me my time
is so limited that i set aside time to
play you're not ruining that by not but
not being here no it's not happening so
i paid what i needed to pay uh
and i accept that
what's funny is like when i told zachary
i was like i was like he sent us a good
amount extra for you to go get food
zach's like oh so i can go because it's
right beside a walmart zachary went over
there and got like fifty dollars with
the junk food they're eating in my car
shout out to song for
i don't know what's going on with stacy
right but beyond stacy
i will say this um
the moment
see everything went haywire right when
everybody was in lockdown right because
now everybody's using all this extra
stuff everybody's online everybody's
this everybody needs more electronics
right so that
all of a sudden there's a shortage right
when we come out of 2020 and the
situation in a lot of places still isn't
considerably better right
it's just going to continue to escalate
and there's going to be this this sort
of this sort of uh this sort of a
situation that continues just to get
worse
now it also all this stuff also happened
at a time when
when you think about the new
technologies coming into the market
right
microsoft is is was out there
pushing all of their servers for cloud
right and
pushing all of that out there in
addition to upgrading them right
then you talk about 5g right 5g was
something that at that moment was the
big thing it was starting to come into
its own now so now all these devices was
5g and whatever so it's just because of
where we're at with technology and how
if you think about it 2020 we have two
new consoles
we have we have oled of beginning to be
like this big thing we have obviously
all the brand new cars coming into the
market
there are so many different devices that
need this silicone
there was always going to be a problem
now when you have a health crisis
all of that becomes priority for in
terms of health stuff in terms of
machinery and stuff like that and i
think we're still there so the problem
is that it this hit at a time when new
things were coming into the world where
it it obviously absolutely least needed
it to happen right and so now we're so
behind the curve that for us to even get
even it's going to take a couple of
years
so
you know at this point like i said
if you really care about having a place
in a playstation or having an xbox if
this is like oh i can't believe i'm
waiting this long
they're out there you're going to pay
for them
yeah i i mean
shout out to kid smooth i didn't have a
ps5 for the longest time and and you
guys can ask the lords i had the money
just chilling waiting for this this
thing after enough of those cues man i'm
every every time i'm in a party okay i'm
like yo you never use that playstation
you know what what do you plan on
selling them can finally crave he's like
all right i will sell you my ps5 but you
gotta buy it all right you can't just
buy the ps5 so i had to buy
i had to buy
the game
he gave me a good price it was it's not
like like you know like it's kind of
like the game stop price but you're
getting it for msn but you have to buy
everything with it yeah no look i'll
jump in he had to buy a bundle yeah
it's just gonna get worse yeah it is
this is crazy i've never seen it and
then kid smooth paid even more money to
get the playstation five a month later
so you know
it's his favorite i've never seen
anything like this
that's why mine's sitting there
collecting dust and i'm blowing into
controllers
so it's like yeah like i've never seen
anything like this it's a year
after release and it's still
difficult to get like this is insane i
want to shout out tom warren from the
verge he said oh yeah sodium is
reportedly the latest to cut back its
targets for the console manufacturing by
1 million it comes after nintendo cut it
switch sales forecast by 1.5 million and
then valve delayed steam deck it's all
due to chip shortages everything is
affected across the board
microsoft
i didn't see that but i remember
the teflon i don't know i think the x is
affected but not the assets the way
they're handing out chains and stuff
mine
yeah look it is what it is and um it
sucks for people who still can't get
consoles but that's all i got we want to
get the super chat or should i go to
poll first while you get the super
chance ready sir yeah let me just roll
back yeah go do it paul go ahead new ilp
poll with the recent reports and leaks
of multiple xbox exclusives planned for
the future which title has you the most
excited to come to the xbox platform the
choices are a obsidian's project
pentiment
b microsoft 1 versus 100 return
c compulsions project midnight or d i
don't care but these xbox leaks are
undefeated please rock the vote when it
goes out
because people out here snitching
telling
everybody we'll say one thing man one
most the time on these xbox insiders say
something it's true can't say that for
the playstations
vpn slide
rock the vote will go up on ilp and log
that and of course the legendary
muffin man rocked out marathon style
with the lords
man tremendous gaming history i think
every lord connected with you on some
level with your gaming history so it's
an absolute pleasure please tell the
five people where they can find you and
what you got going on sir
yeah uh absolutely thank you guys so
much for for having me i know i said on
twitter very humbled to even be invited
uh this is great listen to you guys
every week
um get to 500 subs and then we talk back
to you
that's how the lord play out here
um
so you can find me uh on twitter at the
muffin mon it's on the on the screen
down below at project x talk on twitter
um over on youtube project x talk uh
podcast it goes live every thursday at 5
p.m eastern time unless there's
scheduling conflict like this week we're
doing wednesday with mr boomstick hi why
don't you why don't you come on hang out
with us have some fun but yeah twitter
youtube we're on all audio services so
apple itunes or apple spotify go
subscribe if you list prefer audio and
over youtube but other than that yeah uh
check us out and i appreciate appreciate
being brought on guys no doubt brother
i'm putting your information in chat
projects talk to twitter i got him on
that i got the uh his personal twitter
account and uh you know the medic said
what y'all thought i just want to be
done i thought we was going five hours
stop anyway
but i'm off my salute man and again love
hearing new voices in the community it
was an absolute pleasure when okay you
hit me up and you know sometimes you
know i don't i'll be honest sometimes
i'll just accept advice and i don't know
a lot about the content creator that
advice me and i have to say it was
pleasantly surprised like you guys did
your homework you guys had a great
intellectual discussion very positive
very upbeat and uh i liked it man so we
definitely want to give back pay that
forward and uh get you your time to
shine in the room man an absolute
pleasure we will be back no you don't
worry about your sub count keep doing
what you're doing
you keep grinding know what i'm saying
and then
we'll try to help out as much as ken
because even the lords we started some
win people gave us a shot so salute to
you brother much love
lord addict we're going to find people
find you what you got going on sir you
can follow me on twitter at lord addict
iop you can find me on youtube at gaming
twitter
twitter twitter
this
this friday you can find me playing
shinobi on this channel
uh so you know we'll see how that goes
like
two two and a half hours man i ended up
playing that one i ended up playing
ninja gaiden for for almost like three
and a half hours or something like that
like because because that last boss i i
i was like this boss ain't beating me
excited i put like another 30 minutes
into it just beating that boss but you
know you'll find me doing that uh you
know i appreciate everyone for a couple
three you guys definitely have been
showing up had like 60 70 people
watching that uh you know definitely uh
you know i
this tomorrow at probably 12 o'clock
i'll go live
on the channel because i do want you
guys to come in here and you know we'll
get a good good uh pre-show before this
whatever this uh anniversary thing's
gonna do so definitely
look for this channel probably after the
show i will put up the
the uh the link to tomorrow's show so
definitely looking for that
nice man and i definitely appreciate you
know uh
the muffin i appreciate his brother
and why you don't appreciate him and
jess's brother
i appreciate his brother from showing up
because that's who's on the show right
now his brother
i appreciate him for showing up
[Music]
louis
quickly
find you what you got going on for a
second big shout out to the muffin man i
gotta give him props because anybody
else would have just picked like muffin
man xx69 whatever something like that
he was like nah i'm going with muffin
mod
i love it but they don't think he
would've went with muffin man but they
took it
mm-hmm add some numbers or whatever then
you're good right but he was like no i'm
not doing that i'm not doing that
i'm making it my own so i appreciate
that and like cox said man
anytime we get
excited
uh content creators coming on here
just kind of making their way in just
jumping on a lot of times jumping on
because of the influence influence you
get from us like you see us from the
beginning
doing this and trying and having fun and
you're like man you know what i'm just
gonna do this and uh to see people
following their dreams in that way is
fantastic so again much love to you and
the guys on the panel over there shout
out to mayday ball but his brother said
shout out to me i put in a lot of hard
work on the show apparently
yeah there you go
get to yourself nah but shout out to you
guys uh fantastic what you guys are
doing and just keep growing just keep
going and doing what you do keep doing
what you do
for me actually yeah i have i'm actually
going to the circus later with ladies
ladies i've got some brands
[Music]
we have the the small little circus over
here oh you're going to the barrio
circles
my nephew my nephew was going with us
right my nephew's like um
yeah i don't like clowns
like he was like
you think you could bring the switch
with you and i could play this witch
while everybody else is watching the
show like no you can't do this like
so it should be very interesting he's
forcing the clown action
and later later on i i will be recording
watching it
what you recording what you recording
i'll be i will be recording my uh
impressions on the gta trilogy with lady
april
look for it later this week it's gonna
be an interesting conversation oh i
can't wait say the least
lord king we're gonna find people
finding what you got going on sir
first and foremost i want to thank kevin
i see
i know i'm like
this dude i found this dude
and then i was like oh
the muffin man
so he sees all my messy on twitter
all right so a lot of times before the
guest comes on you know cog is sending
us uh some videos to watch to get some
background history on um the guests
i don't do it um
[Laughter]
[Applause]
outstanding research
[Music]
you know why you know why
you would
you don't know what mind space that
person was in that day
right so you don't know where they were
at what they were dealing whatever and
you might not have that same individual
that day so you go in gearing yourself
to that individual
i don't do that because i i as you see
the music i come in with and i try to
uplift the spirits and get us going you
know for the show
um
you were thoroughly entertaining and
engaging
first i did not know you was a twin i
would have never got that information
from you know watching a show of you
having an interview with somebody else
asking them questions you understand
because you're getting to know that
guest and we're getting to know you and
give you your flowers so we learned that
the playstation 5 was your first
playstation we know that your history
with nintendo went back to grandma
you're like why does grandma have a i
know in the house because she was a
secret gamer
and it's like that little history and
that stuff
everything that went on with your
journey all the way through is so
fantastic and it's i'm so
happy that i did get a chance to
understand your journey and know you
right so and your brother is there from
beginning to the end i like how brother
rolled out i was fine i understand like
if i had a twin that's me and him like
rocking like for real how mad we was
when we could get family members and
friends to watch i understand and we was
like where are you at it was five of the
chat and we don't use the six and you
wasn't there continue that means a lot
that means a hell of a lot the level of
support that your family has for each
other that means a lot because sometimes
when you're in a dark space you need
that support you need to look over to
the chat to see your brother going
that's right get it yeah that's right
let's go
you know so uh salute to you sir
not many people rock out all the way
from beginning to finish yeah and you
did and i appreciate that because it can
get tiresome yeah yeah we out of pocket
we know we're out of control but we you
know thank you yes all right so um
listen guys what you doing we have a ton
of new merch up like we said all of you
guys that did actually purchase merch
thank you i do appreciate everything
that you did um 15 000 subs when we hit
15 000 subs we will give away a console
wayne stingy with the bucks chuck yeah
we got it so if if y'all vote on a
playstation 5 and it's a chip shortage
get yourself a place we'll give you
kings
we'll send it we'll send it to a custom
artist and we'll get look at the all
night
yo that's really where it should go
on the console
that's what we'll do fifteen thousand
could you get you a custom xbox series x
or a ps5 oh man wow he just took it he
took it to the next level
[Laughter]
elite controller coming in hot tomorrow
yeah you got the email
um you can catch me on dcx uh uh legion
of doom friday nights at 9 00 pm we had
a crazy lit show the other night
i really suggest you go look at it
because we talked about the eternals and
all you frauds out here talking about
do my eternals you don't even
i wish we got a chance to talk about
that because you know i got the original
first 19 issues of the run from the king
kirby jack kirby uh who who blessed us
with this uh wonderful story but again
go watch dcx and go see that oh go watch
on the rail where i was with uh k asante
[Music]
um mr johnson over there
we talked the eternals so much we didn't
get a chance to talk uh the harder they
fall so this week we'll be talking the
holiday fall on on the rail um
this is wonderful stuff great content
creators and again sir thank you so much
for rocking out with us thank you
brother
so i did look we fought we got five new
members this this podcast so we're about
seven away from our next like stream
okay so you know you you get get you
neither seven new members or seven
merchandise and you know we might we'll
we'll schedule that new next stream man
all right no doubt no doubt solve you
got the super chats ready hopefully
why the hell would it be mario party
just because that's that's the game no
mario party was was it up against
battlefield 2042
no was it i'm not playing battlefield
okay so this is what i i suggest i
suggest each lord picks a game if
they're not in in conjunction with the
other lords each lord picks a game and
we vote for that game to to be the next
streaming game
my vote is battlefield 20
that's all
i got to think about that one not even
thinking all right yeah cool
i got to think about it but i knew it
wasn't mario party i don't know
you know the funny thing about mario
party you know you know what's funny
about mario party though it is it's not
about skill it's just luck so
can it turn into s show that we could
turn into comedy yes yes 100 percent i
never played with
how would my switch turn on and how
would i wait i never played fix your
face i see you
how would i link to you well see this is
what they ordered
no actually there's this mario party's
uh one of the first games they have on
the new network
okay this this will require me to
purchase said new network to to ben and
nina nintendo to play a game that i
don't have and don't care about that
will only be played
let me see let me say one thing let me
see one thing king
um i had to pl i have to play
battle toes
i had to play shinobi balcony
so let me ask you a question you jump
out the window you found out the floor
hurt is it my fault
the thing is i'm jumping out the window
and i'm putting a little button and
you're coming down soon
see i saw you fall and i said no i could
easily say yo i'mma join him too and
play these old hell no i did it a long
time ago
it's gonna be one of those things where
i got a bungee cord wrapped around you
wrapped around that chain you coming
what vote i say vote is the only way we
will vote
okay we will we will let them
we will let the members and the patreons
yeah one of four games yeah let's go we
added together yeah let the rumble with
me
oh what exactly the real vote i said
they with me
okay cool so yeah let the rebel vote the
realm will pick four games you know
those who are members those who are
patreons i feel like we gotta agree on
the four games man like wow that's what
the realm wants they make us who we are
no no i know i feel like the lord's got
to agree on the four games like to for
for a post i don't want to play
battlefield keep something else
that's what they want yeah no king wants
battlefield in the pole yeah but that'll
definitely go
to play another to to any game besides
battlefield king any game besides
battlefield man may i i will play any
game besides that game oh my lord anyway
we'll see let's see
we'll see what the realm anyway moving
on so we got these super chats ready
today
yeah hold on a second i got derailed
here yeah um
i like the shoe we got
don otaku five dollars can we talk about
how xbox has two upcoming with a focus
on black culture slash black protagonist
with midnight and shaolin
that's what i'm saying i'll see he see
the deeper picture i was doing happy
right now death loop makes three loving
it that is true
and then we got louis bill five dollar
super chat sorry to get off topic but
did you see the moon night teaser i did
lost my mind i didn't yeah
lost my mind yeah did you see moonlight
right there
so i lost we don't see nothing oh you
don't it's off it's off to oh
then we got flame five dollars for chat
just to be super clear i've always stood
by compulsing games even through we have
a few can't wait to see others put
respect on their name
be interesting
then we got gerald mack two dollar super
chat iop podcast of the year thank you
sir always right appreciate that
then we got raiden blade five pounds
super chat monday it's with respect to
the playground games to allow forza
horizon 5 to spend more time in the
light as we feel that halo may distract
gamers from completion
i mean completing forza horizon 5 is a
feat unto itself that's a lot of game
as a whole lot of gig then we got donald
taku 10 super chat
compulsion is the only studio that xbox
bought that isn't proven or worked with
xbox a lot prior but phil bought them on
what their next project was and said
that it was the most excited he was for
it so i believe it so yeah he did say
that he's super excited for that project
so we'll see
then we've got harget cheney
five dollar super chat house mark and
compulsion same size employees return on
aaa can compulsions game also be triple
a
possible we don't know
yeah oh i thought you got i thought i
lost you guys it was so quiet
then we got flame two thousand chat why
do i feel like stacy stole addicts neck
gators
[Music]
yeah
then we got the everborn saga
saab is like me with the playstation 5.
he may not have have fu money but he
does have i don't have time for this
money actually that is true that i was
like nah i don't have time for this yeah
take my money get okay
necromancer
five dollar super chat shout out to
gamestop at xbox or access for having
stock of xbox series x's that's how i
got mine yeah really that's right
10 toes down
okay
then we got mass erratic two dollar
super chat thank you lords for a great
podcast keep hustling thank you my
brother that's a little blessing oh my
god hold up they gotta get they got a
couple of my favorites here oh some
returning i gotta roll back for a minute
uh yeah we got
first off har get your knee five dollar
super chat king phil has thrown down the
gauntlet the premium experience is on
the gucci xbox you're getting one only
10k get that 10k i will see and this is
where my fraud alert comes out on me
there ain't no way in hell you will ever
see me by a 10k console
what
you might see me buy a 10k uh statue
okay you savage you're a savage
there was somebody shaving i had like
flippers in the back no that was this
that was this oh
oh it was down okay
there we go
yeah i was like
i gotta go to work and stop playing with
me
there we go raider blade two possibly
chat phil thanos spencer on that gucci
yeah oh wow crazy
that's great
we ain't getting me to buy it
the rubber now oh
super chat why doesn't attic play the
barbie video guys
no
the last time you guys got me you guys
got me to play that dream daddy never oh
yeah
he played dream daddy that was
classic
not the cat daddy i made that game look
way better than it actually was so shut
up and then we have did you guys see did
you guys see the results of the poll
here we have uh
the halo infinite score
65 out of 50 plus they're good influence
669 votes votes a lot of votes
90 plus 65 everybody's feeling you know
the the positive rights response right
that's it we're caught up all right cool
cool so look we got everything caught up
again tremendous episode listen y'all
appreciate y'all the love tremendous
again muffin thanks for rocking out next
sunday y'all
big show
big show stay tuned we already know
what's going on tomorrow y'all can say
happy birthday to cog now
oh yeah i gotta say happy birthday
happy birthday in the morning
tomorrow most of y'all some of y'all
[Laughter]
look i might be strolling into that
stream
a little bit
[Music]
attic just make sure if i guess i might
roll in five minutes two just make sure
everything's set up
king are you coming to the stream
tomorrow
i'm gonna try my best sir you gotta let
me know the time yeah one one
you got me for tuesday but then also i
got to do um uh colt eastwood show
tomorrow night yeah and then um solve
you your work that is that's a wrap all
right so we'll figure out i'm gonna try
my best
also gotta pull up awesome
you know people wanna join the stream
let me know
no doubt though i appreciate the love
y'all it's not it's not official yet but
king's doing it early
but uh yeah it will be tomorrow but um
yo much love but nick
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's gonna be fun i'm definitely looking
forward to tomorrow um again sunday
y'all y'all don't want to miss i'm
telling you
next monday and we got the 20th
anniversary this week big week much love
y'all thank you for everybody for
hitting the like button all that good
stuff yo enjoy your sunday and thank you
for the birthday wishes ahead of time
appreciate y'all anything anybody else
got addicts off anybody okay we got
anything else we good it's the time
all right let's get up out of here peace
[Music]
so
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
you